Hamed's got the vibe of a guy who can handle anything-- a beefy Tony Soprano type, but without the menace. We're in this big, white, four-wheel-drive pickup truck that he tools around in, me and him and a producer. Sawsan Khalife. And Hamed's task this morning requires ingenuity. His task? He's got to get to work. Step one, get himself out of Hebron, the city where he lives. This is in the West Bank, so movement on the roads is controlled by the Israeli army. And every day, the army changes which exits out of the city are open.
哈米德给人的感觉是一个能应付任何事情的人——像个强壮的托尼·瑟普拉诺（Tony Soprano）那种类型，但没有那种威胁感。我们坐在一辆巨大的白色四驱皮卡里，那是他平时开的车，车上有我和他，还有制片人萨桑·哈利菲（Sawsan Khalife）。哈米德今天早上的任务需要极大的机智。他的任务是什么？他得去上班。第一步，先离开他居住的城市——希伯伦。这位于约旦河西岸，所以道路通行受到以色列军队的控制。每天，军队都会更改城市哪些出口是开放的。
So I checked on many groups which entrance it's easy to go out.
所以我查了许多群组，看看哪个入口容易出去。
These are WhatsApp and Telegram groups. Today, they say that only two roads are open in and out of the city of a quarter million people. We drive to one of them, where a handful of soldiers with assault rifles are manning a checkpoint.
这些是WhatsApp和Telegram群组。今天，他们说这个拥有25万人口的城市只有两条路进出。我们开车前往其中一条，那里有几个拿着突击步枪的士兵正在看守一个检查站。
They open this door around 6:00 at morning.
他们早上6点左右开门。
And we're third in line. There's a gate, and soldiers are going through the cars.
我们排在第三位。那里有个大门，士兵们正在检查车辆。
Yes. Also, most of the time, you will stay here between 10 minutes until one hour.
是的。而且大多数时候，你得在这里待上10分钟到一个小时。
Today, we're lucky. We're early. The line's short. And they wave us through without stopping. After 7:30, Hamed says, they stop every car and it gets really backed up. Hamed works for a company called COMET-ME that sets up solar power, and internet, and water systems in Palestinian villages around the West Bank. So he spends a ton of time driving from place to place and has had to become this kind of weird expert in a thousand details of checkpoints and closed roads and tricks to get around. That suits him.
今天我们很幸运。我们来得早。排队的人很少。他们挥手让我们直接通过，没有拦停。哈米德说，7点半以后，他们会拦下每一辆车，然后就会严重堵车。哈米德为一家名为COMET-ME的公司工作，该公司负责在约旦河西岸的巴勒斯坦村庄安装太阳能、互联网和供水系统。因此，他花大量时间奔波于各地，不得不成为那种精通检查站和封闭道路细节以及绕行技巧的奇特专家。这很适合他。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
I'm the kind of person who likes to talk to everyone, and learn everything, and hear everything, he says. His truck is outfitted with video cameras in case we have any kind of run in with Israeli settlers or the Army. Hamed's had frightening moments when soldiers pulled guns on him. 45 minutes into our drive, he pulls over and points to a winding road that climbs up the side of a long, steep hill in the desert.
“我是那种喜欢和每个人交谈、学习一切、听取一切的人，”他说。他的卡车配备了摄像机，以防我们与以色列定居者或军队发生任何冲突。哈米德曾经历过惊险时刻，士兵们用枪指着他。开车45分钟后，他把车靠边停下，指着一条蜿蜒穿过沙漠中长长的陡峭山坡一侧的道路。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
It's easier to explain this in Arabic, so Sawsan jumps in to translate.
用阿拉伯语解释这一点更容易，所以萨桑插话翻译。
So we can see here, from up the hill way over there, if you could see the road, this is a container crossing.
我们可以从那边的山坡上看到，如果你能看到那条路，那就是“集装箱检查站”。
It's called the container crossing, apparently, because a man used to have a little roadside stand in an old shipping container there. Now it's the notorious checkpoint that divides the north of the West Bank from the south.
显然它被称为“集装箱检查站”，因为过去有个男人在那里的一个旧货运集装箱里摆过小摊。现在，它是臭名昭著的检查站，将约旦河西岸的北部和南部隔离开来。
See, over there, you can see the queue of cars. That means that they're just stopping every car to search the cars. And we can't see any cars moving.
看，在那边，你可以看到排队的汽车。这意味着他们正在拦下每一辆车进行搜查。我们看不到任何车辆在移动。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
I would choose to go to alternative route because we're going to get stuck there for a couple of hours.
我会选择走替代路线，因为我们会被堵在那里几个小时。
One possible alternative route is an unpaved road that curves away in the distance that Hamed points to. But he doesn't like that option, because it delivers you to another checkpoint that could be an hour and a half wait.
哈米德指出的一个可能的替代路线是一条远处弯曲的未铺设路面的土路。但他不喜欢那个选择，因为它会把你引向另一个检查站，可能又要等上一个半小时。
But I have another road. Less people, they know this road.
但我还有另一条路。人比较少，他们知道这条路。
And do you think that's the best one to do?
你认为那是最好的路吗？
Yes. And I will save a lot of time.
是的。这样我会节省很多时间。
OK. We just turned around and made a U-turn.
好吧。我们刚刚调头做了一个U型转弯。
Within minutes, we're off the highway and speeding down a two-lane street with houses close on either side. The danger with this route, Hamed says, is that we're going to drive by an Israeli settlement, where we can get pulled over for hours, though, he has a plan for that. There are people he knows nearby that he can claim that we're visiting if we're stopped. We pop out into a clearing, then turn down an unpaved, rocky-- I don't even want to call this a road. It's more like a ledge on the edge of a cliff.
几分钟内，我们离开了高速公路，在一条两侧房屋紧挨着的双车道街道上疾驰。哈米德说，这条路线的危险在于我们将经过一个以色列定居点，我们可能会在那里被拦下几个小时，不过他对此有一个计划。附近有他认识的人，如果被拦下，他可以声称我们要去拜访他们。我们驶入一片空地，然后转向一条未铺设的、岩石遍布的路——我甚至不想称之为路。它更像是一个悬崖边上的岩架。
Hey, could I just pause just to say, this is one of the worst roads I've ever driven on? The car is rocking left and right, as if we were on a stormy sea. And even to keep the car upright, you're having to weave back and forth.
嘿，我可以暂停一下说一句吗？这是我开过的最烂的路之一。车子在左右摇晃，就像在暴风雨的海面上一样。即使为了保持车身直立，你也不得不左右穿行。
Yeah, I can barely hold my coffee mug.
是啊，我连咖啡杯都快拿不住了。
At one point in this trip, we're on a bumpy, slow road, and Hamed points to an overpass with a freeway that is just for Israelis. Cars with Israeli plates whiz by. They go through fewer checkpoints. This whole unequal road system that's way faster for Israelis and way harder for Palestinians, it's nothing new in the West Bank.
这次旅程中，我们有一段路行驶在崎岖、缓慢的路面上，哈米德指着一座仅供以色列人通行的高速公路立交桥。挂着以色列车牌的汽车呼啸而过。他们经过的检查站更少。这种极其不平等的道路系统——对以色列人来说要快得多，对巴勒斯坦人来说要困难得多——在约旦河西岸早已不是什么新鲜事。
But after October 7, after the Hamas attack, where some 1,200 Israelis were killed and another 250 taken hostage, the worst attack in Israel's history, the Israeli government struck back not just in Gaza, where Hamas is based, where Israel has now killed over 60,000 people. They also took action in the West Bank in all kinds of ways. Just one of them was that they installed hundreds of new checkpoints and roadblocks.
但在10月7日哈马斯袭击之后，约1200名以色列人被杀，另有250人被劫持为人质，这是以色列历史上最严重的袭击。以色列政府不仅在哈马斯的根据地加沙进行了反击，在那里以色列现在已经杀死了超过6万人。他们还以各种方式在约旦河西岸采取了行动。其中之一就是他们安装了数百个新的检查站和路障。
From the highway, you see these yellow and orange gates that are locked shut one after another, blocking off passage to Palestinian villages, isolating them. Sometimes you see people going around the gates and running across the highway to get everyday stuff done. We pass one roadblock. It's a mound of rocks piled 6 or 7 feet high in the middle of a street. Another is a big gate that Hamed points to and says that behind it is a community that his company, COMET, provides services to.
从高速公路上，你可以看到这些黄色和橙色的闸门一个接一个地锁着，阻断了通往巴勒斯坦村庄的通道，将它们隔离开来。有时你会看到人们绕过闸门，跑过高速公路去处理日常事务。我们经过一个路障。那是一堆堆在街道中间、有六七英尺高的大石头。另一个是一个大闸门，哈米德指着它说，后面就是他的公司COMET提供服务的社区。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
And in order for us to be able to get to our communities, we would have to drive-- instead of five minutes to get to them from here, we would have to drive 35 minutes to 40 minutes because the gate now is closed.
为了能够到达我们的社区，我们必须绕路——从这里本来只需5分钟，现在我们必须开车35到40分钟，因为那个门现在关着。
And has this gate been closed permanently since October 7?
这个门从10月7日以来就一直永久关闭吗？
Yes.
是的。
Our trip this morning ends up taking 2 and 1/2 hours. We end up in a tiny village outside Jericho. Hamed says the checkpoints and roadblocks added over an hour to the trip.
今天上午我们的行程最终花了两个半小时。我们最终到达了杰里科外的一个小村庄。哈米德说，检查站和路障让行程增加了一个多小时。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
His team is putting in water filtration and security cameras this particular day. And one of his coworkers was not as lucky on the roads. I'll call him Sam. All these names are made up, by the way. They all worry about retaliation from the Israelis. Sam came to work in this village today from the North, which should have taken less than an hour. But because of a checkpoint, it took six.
他的团队这一天正在安装水过滤系统和安全摄像头。他的一个同事在路上就没那么幸运了。我就叫他“萨姆”。顺便说一下，这些名字都是虚构的。他们都担心遭到以色列人的报复。萨姆今天从北部赶来这个村庄工作，本来应该不到一小时就能到达，但因为检查站，花了六个小时。
Six hours.
六个小时。
Did they search your car?
他们搜查你的车了吗？
This is the point. They didn't check anything. They just want you to suffering in the road. They don't do anything. But they just want to waste your time and humiliate you, just like that. They want to let us know that they are owning these roads.
关键点就在这里。他们什么都没查。他们只是想让你在路上受罪。他们什么都没做。他们只是想浪费你的时间，羞辱你，就是这样。他们想让我们知道，他们拥有这些道路。
So what did you do for six hours?
那么你在那六个小时里做了什么？
Do some works on my laptops, sometimes, sometimes watching the news, sometimes nothing, just hear some songs or something.
有时在笔记本电脑上工作，有时看新闻，有时什么也不做，只是听听歌之类的。
The Israeli military categorically denies that it's using checkpoints and roadblocks to disrupt the lives of Palestinians. A spokesperson wrote to us that security forces operate, quote, "under a complex security reality, where terrorists embed themselves within the civilian population. Accordingly, there are dynamic checkpoints and ongoing efforts to monitor movement." They said the military tries to maintain, quote, "as much as possible, the routine of everyday life of the population of the area."
以色列军方断然否认利用检查站和路障破坏巴勒斯坦人的生活。一位发言人写信告诉我们，安全部队在“复杂的安全现实下运作，恐怖分子混在平民中。因此，存在动态的检查站和持续的监控移动的努力。”他们说军方试图“尽可能多地维持该地区民众日常生活的规律”。
Sam sees it differently. He described the feeling of helplessness that he gets waiting for hours in line at a checkpoint in this way that I didn't totally get at first. Let me share this with you. He says it feels like your hand or some other piece of your body has been cut off and is lying on the ground in front of you. And you see it there. And you can't do anything about it.
萨姆的看法不同。他描述了在检查站排队等待数小时时的那种无助感，这种感觉我起初并不完全理解。让我和你分享一下。他说感觉就像你的手或其他身体部位被切掉，掉在你面前的地上。你看着它在那里，却无能为力。
And you must say it's OK.
而且你必须说“没关系”。
You must say it's OK because--
你必须说没关系，因为……
Because you can't do something about that. It's an occupation.
因为你对此无能为力。这是占领。
It's an occupation, he's saying.
这是占领，他是这样说的。
So much has gotten worse in the West Bank since October 7 for Palestinians-- more violence, more of them driven off their land. The Israeli government has done things to choke the economy. Unemployment has soared. There's been a wave of people arrested and imprisoned with no charges and no trials.
10月7日以来，巴勒斯坦人在约旦河西岸的情况变得更糟——更多的暴力，更多人被赶出土地。以色列政府采取了扼杀经济的举措。失业率飙升。出现了一波未经指控和审判就被逮捕入狱的人。
But I'm starting today's program talking about roadblocks and checkpoints. Because when I talked to people around the West Bank about what feels different since October 7, so many people pointed to just this everyday stuff. Like, the difficulty of getting from place to place has gotten harder. As Hamed put it--
但我今天节目的开头谈到了路障和检查站。因为当我与约旦河西岸各地的人们谈论10月7日以来有什么不同时，许多人都指出了这种日常琐事。比如，从一个地方到另一个地方的难度变大了。正如哈米德所言——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
You can't predict anything, so you're constantly under pressure. There's stress around you all the time.
你无法预测任何事情，所以你一直处于压力之下。你周围一直都有压力。
It squeezes on your life, Hamed says, stresses him out. When he goes to the doctor these days, his blood pressure is higher than in the past. He gets mad about little stuff. He knows that he's overreacting. We're going to spend today's whole show in the West Bank. And I think I should pause now, just so everybody is on the same page about what the West Bank is.
它压榨着你的生活，哈米德说，这让他感到压力很大。这些天他去看医生时，血压比过去高了。他会对小事发火。他知道自己反应过度了。我们要把今天整期节目花在约旦河西岸。我想我应该先暂停一下，让每个人都对约旦河西岸是什么有一个共识。
So if you picture Israel, it's a country roughly the size and shape of New Jersey. Gaza, where the Gaza war's been happening, is a little strip of land carved out in the West. 2 million Palestinians live there, roughly. 3 million Palestinians live in the West Bank. It is a much, much bigger chunk of land on the East side. OK, I know-- east side, West Bank. It's called the West Bank because it runs along the West Bank of the Jordan River.
如果你想象一下以色列，它是一个大约有新泽西州那么大、形状也相似的国家。加沙，也就是加沙战争发生的地方，是西边开辟出来的一小片土地。大约有200万巴勒斯坦人住在那里。300万巴勒斯坦人住在约旦河西岸。那是东侧一块大得多、多得多的土地。好吧，我知道——东侧，却叫西岸（West Bank）。它之所以被称为西岸，是因为它沿着约旦河的西岸延伸。
Israel took over the West Bank and Gaza in a war in 1967 and put them under military occupation until It figured out whether it was going to make that land part of Israel or give it to the Palestinian people in exchange for peace. If the Palestinian people are ever going to get their own state, the West Bank will probably be the heart of it. Still with me?
以色列在1967年的战争中接管了约旦河西岸和加沙，并将它们置于军事占领之下，直到它弄清楚是要将那片土地并入以色列，还是将其交换给巴勒斯坦人民以换取和平。如果巴勒斯坦人民有朝一日能拥有自己的国家，约旦河西岸很可能就是它的核心。还在听吗？
All right. So trying to understand what was happening on the West Bank, there's this kind of remarkable document that I learned about. It was written by the Israeli government minister who was called the Overlord of the West Bank by one Israeli publication because, basically, he calls the shots there for the current government.
好了。为了了解西岸正在发生什么，我了解到一份相当引人注目的文件。它是由一位以色列政府部长撰写的，他被一家以色列出版物称为“约旦河西岸的霸主”，因为基本上，现任政府在那里的一切决策都由他说了算。
His name is Bezalel Smotrich. And before he got this job, back in 2017, when he was a member of the Israeli parliament, he published a manifesto whose title roughly translates to "The Decisive Plan," in which he argues that as long as Palestinians continue to hope for their own homeland, the conflict between Jews and Palestinians is going to continue forever. They'll always be at war.
他的名字是比扎雷尔·斯莫特里赫（Bezalel Smotrich）。在得到这份工作之前，也就是2017年，当他还是以色列议会议员时，他发表了一份宣言，题目大致翻译为“决定性计划”。他在文中认为，只要巴勒斯坦人继续希望拥有自己的家园，犹太人和巴勒斯坦人之间的冲突就会永远持续下去。他们将永远处于战争状态。
And so he says Israel's first goal should be to destroy hope, destroy Palestinians' hopes of ever getting their own state or homeland. And he says Israel can do that by claiming more land and building more homes for Jews, by changing the facts on the ground until, for Palestinians, quote, "The point will come when frustration will cross the threshold of despair and will lead to acceptance and understanding that their cause stands no chance. It simply isn't going to happen."
所以他说，以色列的首要目标应该是摧毁希望，摧毁巴勒斯坦人获得自己国家或家园的希望。他说，以色列可以通过要求更多的土地和为犹太人建造更多的家园，通过改变地面上的事实来实现这一点，直到对巴勒斯坦人来说，“挫败感将跨过绝望的门槛，导致他们接受并理解他们的事业没有任何机会。这根本不会发生。”
At that point, he says Israel should offer them a choice-- leave and go elsewhere, or stay as second-class residents, not full citizens. And Israel will be a Jewish state, quote, "from the river to the sea."
他说，到那时，以色列应该给他们一个选择——离开并去往别处，或者作为二等居民留下来，而不是完整的公民。以色列将是一个“从河流到海洋”的犹太国家。
Smotrich turned down our request for an interview. But in the last two weeks, he made international headlines describing his current intentions for the West Bank.
斯莫特里赫拒绝了我们的采访请求。但在过去两周里，他因描述他对约旦河西岸的当前意图而登上了国际新闻头条。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语对话]
He was at an Israeli settlement outdoors at a podium, announcing that Israel was going to be building thousands of new homes in the West Bank in a spot that would effectively split the West Bank in half. The line that made international headlines was when Smotrich said, "This reality completely buries the idea of a Palestinian state."
他在一个以色列定居点的露天讲台上宣布，以色列将在约旦河西岸建造数千个新家园，地点将有效地将约旦河西岸一分为二。那句引发国际头条的话是，斯莫特里赫说：“这种现实彻底埋葬了巴勒斯坦国的想法。”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语对话]
In the last few weeks, France, Britain, Australia, and Canada have announced their intention to possibly recognize a Palestinian state. And Smotrich addressed those countries directly in his speech in terms that echoed his decisive plan.
在过去几周里，法国、英国、澳大利亚和加拿大宣布了他们可能承认巴勒斯坦国的意向。斯莫特里赫在他的演讲中直接回应了这些国家，其措辞与他的“决定性计划”相呼应。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语对话]
He's saying, anybody who tries to recognize a Palestinian state today in the world will receive our answer on the ground, not in documents, not in decisions or statements, but in facts-- facts of houses, facts of neighborhoods, roads, and more and more Jewish families that build lives.
他是说，任何今天试图在世界上承认巴勒斯坦国的人，都将得到我们在地面上的回应，而不是在文件中，不是在决定或声明中，而是在事实中——房屋的事实、社区的事实、道路的事实，以及越来越多建立生活的犹太家庭的事实。
Today on our show, we go to the West Bank. I think the horror of what has been happening in Gaza has taken up so much of our attention that lots of us, me included, haven't really taken in the dramatic changes in the West Bank since October 7 in settlements, in violence, in daily life under Minister Smotrich and the current government.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要去约旦河西岸。我想加沙正在发生的恐怖事件占据了我们太多的注意力，以至于我们很多人，包括我在内，并没有真正注意到10月7日以来约旦河西岸在定居点、暴力以及斯莫特里赫部长和现任政府统治下的日常生活方面发生的剧烈变化。
Israel's actions right now in the West Bank seem to have two goals-- to crush the idea that a Palestinian state will ever be there and, as Smotrich wrote in 2017, to drive Palestinians to cross the threshold of despair. When he wrote that he was talking about building Israeli settlements, but I think it might also describe lots of things that have been happening lately. Some of the details of this really surprised me. I'm guessing they might surprise you too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
以色列目前在约旦河西岸的行动似乎有两个目标——摧毁那里永远会有巴勒斯坦国的想法，以及正如斯莫特里赫2017年所写的，驱使巴勒斯坦人跨越绝望的门槛。当他写下这些时，他谈论的是建立以色列定居点，但我认为这可能也描述了最近发生的许多事情。其中一些细节真的让我感到惊讶。我猜它们可能也会让你惊讶。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, our show today about the West Bank. Act One, Ali and the Duster. So the current Israeli government took power about a year before October 7. From the start, it's been aggressively on the side of helping Jewish settlers build more homes and take more territory in the West Bank. Minister Smotrich talks about this proudly, how they've approved record numbers of new homes for Israelis there. All these settlements are seen as illegal under international law by most of the international community.
这是《美国生活》，我们今天节目关于约旦河西岸。第一幕，阿里和达斯特（Duster）汽车。现任以色列政府在10月7日前约一年上台。从一开始，它就积极站在帮助犹太定居者在约旦河西岸建造更多家园和夺取更多领土的一边。斯莫特里赫部长自豪地谈论这一点，他们如何批准了在那里为以色列人建造的新家园数量达到创纪录水平。根据大多数国际社会的观点，所有这些定居点在国际法下都被视为非法的。
But as part of that expansion, settlers have been pushing Palestinians off their land in the West Bank in record numbers. A group in Israel that monitors settlement expansion, Peace Now's Settlement Watch project, says that since October 7, settlers have pushed more than 80 Palestinian communities off their land. Before October 7, settlers had only done that six times. And there's way more violence now against Palestinians in the West Bank, by the Israeli military and Israeli settlers, since October 7, and way more Palestinians killed than in the past.
但作为这种扩张的一部分，定居者一直在创纪录地将巴勒斯坦人赶出他们在约旦河西岸的土地。以色列一个监测定居点扩张的组织“现在和平”（Peace Now）的定居点观察项目表示，自10月7日以来，定居者已经将超过80个巴勒斯坦社区赶出了他们的土地。在10月7日之前，定居者只做过六次。而且自10月7日以来，约旦河西岸针对巴勒斯坦人的暴力事件大幅增加，既来自以色列军方，也来自以色列定居者，被杀的巴勒斯坦人比过去多得多。
Hagit Ofran, the co-director of Settlement Watch, described Israel's attitude since October 7 this way.
定居点观察联合主任哈吉特·奥夫兰（Hagit Ofran）这样描述以色列自10月7日以来的态度。
Everything can be justified because look what they did to us, look how dangerous they are. But I think also, the feeling of settlers now, that they are in charge. They have no limits. They have their back covered by this government. They can do whatever they want. Nobody's going to hurt them. That's a big change.
一切都可以被合理化，因为看看他们对我们做了什么，看看他们有多危险。但我认为，定居者现在也有一种感觉，他们负责了。他们没有限制。他们的背后有这个政府支持。他们可以随心所欲。没人会伤害他们。这是一个巨大的变化。
One of the producers of today's show is an Israeli journalist, Yael Even Or. She was interested in what it's like for these Palestinian communities coming under all this increased pressure to leave. And she was calling around, talking to lots of people, until somebody said to her, you know who should call about this? Ali Awad.
今天节目的一位制片人是以色列记者耶尔·埃文·奥尔（Yael Even Or）。她对这些巴勒斯坦社区在受到如此巨大的离开压力时是什么样子很感兴趣。她到处打电话，和很多人交谈，直到有人对她说，你知道你应该给谁打电话吗？阿里·阿瓦德（Ali Awad）。
Ali's 27. He lives in a tiny village called Tuba, one of 19 villages in an area called Masafer Yatta, where they filmed that movie No Other Land that won the Oscar this year and where the intimidation and harassment has been intense. Ali had been studying for his masters in English. He wanted to be a college English teacher. But instead, he's become kind of the protector of his little village.
阿里27岁。他住在图巴（Tuba）的一个小村庄，这是马萨费尔亚塔（Masafer Yatta）地区19个村庄之一，那里拍摄了今年获得奥斯卡的电影《没有其他土地》（No Other Land），那里的恐吓和骚扰一直非常激烈。阿里一直在攻读英语硕士学位。他想成为一名大学英语老师。但相反，他成了他小村庄的保护者。
Yael talked to him over months, as he had to deal with an escalating series of events that really demonstrate how things are changing in lots of parts of the West Bank. Here's Yael.
耶尔与他进行了几个月的交谈，因为他不得不处理一系列不断升级的事件，这些事件真正展示了约旦河西岸许多地方的情况正在发生变化。这是耶尔。
When I first talked to Ali, back in November, the main thing he was doing all day was driving people around-- to their doctor's appointments, family gatherings, the police station. He has the only car in Tuba, one car for 80 people
当我第一次和阿里交谈时，那是11月，他整天做的主事就是开车送人——去赴医生的预约、家庭聚会、警察局。他有图巴唯一的车，80个人共用一辆车。
I am every day available, like 24/7, all the month.
我每天24/7随时待命，整整一个月。
And how do you manage your calendar or schedule? Do you write it down somewhere if someone says I need to go there on Sunday?
你是如何管理你的日历或日程的？如果有人说周日需要去那里，你会把它写下来吗？
Yeah. I have a group on my WhatsApp called Talk to Myself, which is only myself.
是的。我在WhatsApp上有一个群组叫“自言自语”，只有我自己。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I check it every evening to see what, tomorrow, I'm up to.
所以我每天晚上检查一下，看看明天要做什么。
Ali's car is important to Tuba because the village is totally isolated. There's only one road in and out. Tuba is way up on a hill, and the road is rocky, valleys right below you. It requires a skilled driver and an SUV.
阿里的车对图巴很重要，因为这个村庄完全与世隔绝。只有一条路进出。图巴高高地位于山顶，道路岩石遍布，下面就是山谷。它需要一个技术精湛的司机和一辆SUV。
But what probably makes it hardest to go in and out of Tuba are the settlements. They surround Tuba on three sides and cut it off from the rest of the Palestinian villages nearby. The Palestinians can't walk or drive through them, so Ali drives everyone up and down the rocky hill. He told me he's the taxi driver, the grocery delivery guy, and the ambulance driver, all combined.
但进出图巴最困难的可能还是定居点。它们在三个方向包围了图巴，并将它与附近其他巴勒斯坦村庄隔绝开来。巴勒斯坦人不能步行或开车穿过它们，所以阿里开车送每个人上下这崎岖的山坡。他告诉我，他既是出租车司机，又是杂货配送员，还是救护车司机，三者合一。
One of the first things you see when you get to Tuba are the animals. Ali's family are shepherds. He gave me a tour. There are camels, chickens, goats, and hundreds of sheep.
当你到达图巴时，首先看到的是动物。阿里家是牧羊人。他带我参观了一下。有骆驼、鸡、山羊和数百只羊。
It's the time for them to start getting fertilized for the first time.
现在是它们第一次受孕的时候。
How do they get fertilized, as you said?
正如你所说，它们是如何受孕的？
Naturally. They--
自然地。它们……
They just hook up?
它们就直接交配吗？
Yes, they just hook up. But we have kind of a medicine, hormones that will motivate the appetite.
是的，它们直接交配。但我们有一种药物，是能刺激食欲的荷尔蒙。
I was waiting to see what words you're going to use for this.
我等着看你会用什么词来形容这个。
[LAUGHS] To motivate the appetite is OK word?
[笑] 刺激食欲是合适的词吗？
It's good enough for public radio, I think yeah.
我想对公共广播来说已经够好了。
So... [SPEAKING ARABIC]
所以…… [阿拉伯语对话]
Ali's telling his cousin, Jude, who's nine, to get off the tractor. Here's the other thing you'd see in Tuba right away, besides the animals. It's Israel's flag, which feels completely out of place overlooking this Palestinian village. It's at the top of the hill, just above Ali's family's compound. Ali thinks it was placed there by settlers from the nearby outpost, Chavat Maon. Right after October 7, they built a road from the outpost to the top of the hill.
阿里正在告诉他九岁的表弟朱德（Jude）从拖拉机上下来。这是你在图巴会立即看到的除了动物之外的另一件事。那是以色列的国旗，它俯瞰着这个巴勒斯坦村庄，感觉完全格格不入。它位于山顶，就在阿里家族院落的正上方。阿里认为它是附近前哨站Chavat Maon的定居者插在那里的。10月7日刚过，他们就修了一条从前哨站到山顶的路。
And they put this flag, you see, 200 meters from here. If I get there, I will be arrested.
他们把这面旗帜插在离这里200米的地方。如果我走到那里，我就会被捕。
The flag hovers over Tuba-- a reminder from the settlers, day and night, we're right here.
这面旗帜笼罩在图巴上空——定居者日夜提醒着，我们就住在这里。
One of the first problems that cropped up after October 7 that kept Ali and his car busy was how to get kids to school. For 19 years, the kids from Tuba had the Israeli military escort them as they walked to school, sometimes with an armored military vehicle. Because to get to school, they had to walk through Chavat Maon, the outpost. And the settlers would attack them on their way, throw rocks at them.
10月7日后出现的第一个让阿里和他的车忙碌的问题是如何送孩子们上学。19年来，图巴的孩子们都有以色列军队护送他们步行去上学，有时甚至有装甲军车。因为要去学校，他们必须穿过前哨站Chavat Maon。定居者会在他们上学的路上攻击他们，向他们扔石头。
It happened to Ali when he was a kid. I actually found some footage of him in an old Al Jazeera story. Ali was 17 at the time.
阿里小的时候也遇到过这种情况。我实际上在一段旧的半岛电视台报道中找到了他的一段视频。阿里当时17岁。
Sometimes they throw rocks, a lot of rocks, a lot of rocks as rain falling.
有时他们扔石头，扔很多石头，就像雨点一样落下。
After October 7, the military refused to escort the kids anymore. The military told us that this decision was due to a lack of manpower and for security reasons. So Ali added to his list school bus driver. He started driving the kids, as many as 14 of them. They'd all try to cram in. Sometimes it would take two trips.
10月7日后，军方拒绝再护送孩子们。军方告诉我们，这个决定是由于人力不足和安全原因。所以阿里在他的名单上增加了一个任务：校车司机。他开始开车送孩子们，多达14个。他们都试图挤进去。有时需要跑两趟。
What do the kids talk about in the car?
孩子们在车里聊什么？
Sometimes about candies. [LAUGHS] Sometimes about homeworks.
有时聊糖果。[笑] 有时聊家庭作业。
Ali now knows a bunch of not-very-important secrets, he tells me. The school is actually pretty close by, about 1.5 miles, but he has to take this long way around because he can't go near the outpost. The roundtrip takes him a little over an hour. That's the nature of the occupation in the West Bank. It makes the Palestinians constantly work harder to get back to the thing that was normal a second ago, even though it wasn't even normal in the first place.
阿里现在知道一堆不太重要的秘密，他告诉我。学校其实很近，大约1.5英里，但他必须走这条长长的绕路，因为他不能靠近前哨站。往返需要一个多小时。这就是约旦河西岸占领的本质。它迫使巴勒斯坦人不断更加努力地回到一秒钟前还是正常状态的事情，尽管那时其实也根本不正常。
The house Ali shares with his uncle and aunt is on a little rise. His room doesn't have much on the walls. He's not big on decorations. There are only two photos. Both of them are of his car. One is a total glam shot of the car at the car wash.
阿里和他的叔叔婶婶住的房子在一个小坡上。他的房间墙上没多少东西。他不怎么搞装饰。只有两张照片。两张都是他的车。一张是这辆车在洗车处的照片。
I took this picture and sent to my mom. Because here, the car gets very dusty. And she was always telling me, you need also to clean the car sometimes. So I sent her a photo showing how clean the car could be.
我拍了这张照片发给我妈妈。因为这里车子非常多灰尘。她总是对我说，你需要偶尔清洗一下车子。所以我发给她一张照片，展示车子可以有多干净。
Can I just say, the way you took this picture, I'm getting the feeling that you're very proud of this car.
我可以这么说吗，你拍这张照片的方式，让我感觉到你非常为这辆车自豪。
Yeah, you can see. Some people also use the pronoun "it" for the car. I use the pronoun "she" for her. And people would say, you are in a relationship with this car.
是的，你可以看出来。有些人也用代词“它”来指代车子。我用代词“她”来指代她。人们会说，你和这辆车在谈恋爱。
Ali bought her after the first car he got broke on the highway one day. Not to name names, but it was a Kia Sportage. This one is much better, a Romanian car, a Dacia Duster, an SUV. His is white. If cars had faces, I'd say this one is frowning. Ali keeps it in top shape, so it never breaks down near a settlement and can always get out of a dangerous situation quickly. He spends nearly all of his money on it.
阿里在第一辆车某天在高速公路上抛锚后买了她。不指名道姓，那是一辆起亚狮跑。这一辆好得多，一辆罗马尼亚车，达契亚达斯特（Dacia Duster），一辆SUV。他的是白色的。如果车有脸，我会说这一辆在皱眉头。阿里让车保持在最佳状态，所以它从不在定居点附近抛锚，并且总能迅速脱离危险情况。他几乎所有的钱都花在它身上了。
I don't have kids. I don't have my own kids. I don't have other expenses than my cigarettes and my car. Spending all your life, your energy, your money on the car is to, as a driver, to make sure that everyone in your car in the journey is safe as-- as much as possible.
我没有孩子。我没有自己的孩子。我除了香烟和车之外没有其他开销。把你的余生、你的精力、你的钱花在车上，是为了作为一个司机，确保车上的每个人在旅途中尽可能安全。
The thing is, it's not just Palestinians in the area who know the Dacia Duster. Some settlers know it too. In January, three months after October 7, Ali was driving his neighbor. They were on the highway. Suddenly, another driver threw a glass bottle at them. It shattered a mirror. It was very scary. Ali thinks it might have been a nearby settler who recognized his car. The neighbor told Ali he should drive less, keep a low profile. But Ali kept on driving.
问题是，不仅仅是该地区的巴勒斯坦人认识这辆达契亚达斯特。一些定居者也认识它。1月，也就是10月7日三个月后，阿里正开车送他的邻居。他们在高速公路上。突然，另一名司机向他们扔了一个玻璃瓶。镜子碎了。非常可怕。阿里认为那可能是附近认出他车的定居者。邻居告诉阿里他应该少开车，保持低调。但阿里继续开着。
The first settlers near Tuba set up shop in 1981. Today, about 550 people live there. The settlement's called Maon. They have schools, a library, youth club. 20 years later, an outpost, Chavat Maon, was established nearby. It's illegal under Israeli law. And nearly 20 years after that, Chavat Maon sprung its own illegal outpost called Maane Farm after the local settler leader who started it, Isaschar Maane.
图巴附近的定居者于1981年开始立足。今天，大约有550人住在那里。这个定居点叫Maon。他们有学校、图书馆、青年俱乐部。20年后，附近建立了一个前哨站Chavat Maon。根据以色列法律，它是非法的。又过了近20年，Chavat Maon衍生出了自己的非法前哨站Maane Farm，以发起它的当地定居者领袖Isaschar Maane的名字命名。
This newer outpost is a sheep farm and a sort of Airbnb-type setup with a campsite as well. It has 106 Google reviews with an average of 4.9 stars. Ali has known Isaschar Maane since he was a kid. He remembers him harassing them on their way to school. And nowadays, he sees him around Tuba, he says, at least once a week. We reached out to Isaschar Maane for comment but did not hear back. His wife told us he had no interest in speaking.
这个较新的前哨站是一个牧羊场，也是一种带有露营地的Airbnb式场所。它在谷歌上有106条评论，平均4.9星。阿里从孩提时代就认识Isaschar Maane。他记得他骚扰他们在上学路上的情景。如今，他说他至少每周能在图巴附近看到他一次。我们联系了Isaschar Maane寻求置评，但没有得到回复。他的妻子告诉我们他没兴趣说话。
Before October 7, the settlers would mainly mess with the Palestinians when they got close to the settlements. Since October 7, the settlers are closing in on the residents of Tuba and even entering the village. Ali told me and my producer, Dana, about a day last summer.
10月7日之前，定居者主要是当巴勒斯坦人靠近定居点时找他们麻烦。自10月7日以来，定居者正在向图巴的居民逼近，甚至进入村庄。阿里告诉我和我的制片人达娜（Dana）关于去年夏天发生的一天的事。
It was around 8:00, half past 8:00 in the morning or 9:00. My uncle was grazing, like, 300 sheep under his house, where we are sitting, 200 meters under us.
那是早上8点半或9点左右。我叔叔正在房子下面，也就是我们现在坐的地方，200米以下放牧300只羊。
This valley right below us, just below?
就在我们正下方的这个山谷里？
The bottom of this valley just below us. And suddenly, he saw four masked settlers--
就在正下方的这个山谷底部。突然，他看到了四个蒙面的定居者——
Four settlers wearing masks.
四个戴面具的定居者。
--in the middle of his flock. Two started to run towards him, to scare him. And in the same time, two start to take the sheep to the settlement.
——出现在他的羊群中间。两个开始向他跑来，吓唬他。与此同时，另外两个开始把羊往定居点赶。
How many did they get?
他们抓走了多少？
They took everything.
他们抓走了全部。
All the sheep?
所有的羊？
All the sheep. They start to run with the sheep. And his wife and himself were screaming at me, the settlers took everything we have, and come help us.
所有的羊。他们开始赶着羊跑。他的妻子和他自己对我尖叫，定居者抢走了我们拥有的一切，快来救我们。
So Ali comes running and starts recording on his phone. Halfway up a big hill, he finds them. At the start of the video, you see two men. They're young, wearing masks. They both have large sticks in their hands. One has a rock as well. They're threatening his aunt.
所以阿里跑过去，开始用手机录像。在一座大山的半山腰，他找到了他们。视频开头，你看到两个男人。他们很年轻，戴着面具。他们手里都拿着大棍子。其中一个还拿着石头。他们正在威胁他的婶婶。
Ali's pleading with them in Hebrew. Stop. Stop. Put down the rock. The men yell at Ali to go home. When he starts running back, they chase him. But then something surprising happens.
阿里用希伯来语哀求他们。停下。停下。放下石头。男人们对阿里大喊让他回家。当他开始往回跑时，他们追他。但随后发生了一些令人惊讶的事情。
While they were attacking us for a couple of minutes, our sheep ran back to our house, [LAUGHS] to the direction of our house, out of their hands, out of their control.
当他们攻击我们几分钟时，我们的羊跑回了我们的房子，[笑] 回到我们房子的方向，脱离了他们的手，脱离了他们的控制。
Ali is proud when he tells the story because it was a rare victory-- 300 sheep saved. Sheep theft has become an increasingly common phenomenon in the West Bank. A lot of times people don't get them back, which means losing their entire livelihood. Ali says 300 sheep are worth roughly $125,000. I've seen even higher estimates.
阿里在讲这个故事时很自豪，因为这是一次罕见的胜利——救下了300只羊。偷羊在约旦河西岸变得越来越普遍。很多时候人们要不回它们，这意味着失去了他们的全部生计。阿里说300只羊大约价值12.5万美元。我甚至见过更高的估计。
Ali doesn't really sleep at night anymore, thanks to the constant threats from settlers and his own hypervigilance. So he stays up most of the night and keeps watch over the village. He started doing this a few months before October 7. But after, he got even more anxious.
由于定居者的持续威胁和他自己的高度警惕，阿里晚上再也睡不着觉了。所以他整晚大部分时间都熬着，监视着村庄。他在10月7日前几个月就开始这样做了。但在那之后，他变得更加焦虑。
The government handed out weapons in settlements, at least 3,000 of them in the first two weeks of the war. They also gave ATVs to settlers near Tuba. And a lot more settlers began walking around in military uniforms.
政府在定居点分发武器，仅在战争的前两周就发了至少3000支。他们还给图巴附近的定居者提供了全地形车（ATV）。越来越多的定居者开始穿着军装走来走去。
I called Ali while he was up one night. He was in his room, sitting on his couch, getting up to go to the door every few minutes, where he had a good view of the family compound. He was drinking tea and smoking.
有一天晚上，阿里还没睡，我给他打了电话。他坐在房间的沙发上，每隔几分钟就站起来走到门口，那里可以很好地看到家族院落。他正喝着茶抽着烟。
How many cigarettes do you do usually go through?
你通常抽多少支烟？
In the night?
在晚上？
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, Between 7 to 10. You don't smoke, right?
是啊，7到10支之间。你不抽烟，对吧？
I stopped. I quit.
我戒了。我不再抽了。
Great.
太好了。
Yes. [LAUGHS] When I was a little older than you, I quit. So you have some time. But you should quit.
是的。[笑] 我比你大一点的时候就戒了。所以你还有时间。但你应该戒掉。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Sometimes it's quiet. Nothing happens. Other nights, it's not.
有时很安静。什么也没发生。其他晚上则不然。
Just right now, while I'm talking with you, I hear outside of my room that a settler on ATV just passed through our villages.
就在现在，我和你说话的时候，我听到我房间外有一个定居者骑着ATV经过我们的村子。
Wow. So there are settlers there now?
哇。所以现在有定居者在那儿？
Yes. Like, outside of my door, there is a settler right now.
是的。就像在我门外，现在就有一个定居者。
No reason for the settlers to pass through Tuba-- they have much better roads on the other side of their outposts. Sometimes Ali shines a big flashlight at them as they drive by so they know he's there, keeping an eye out.
定居者根本没理由经过图巴——他们的前哨站另一侧有更好的路。有时阿里在他们经过时用大手电筒照他们，好让他们知道他在那里，在盯着。
After a few months of taking the kids to school, Ali found a different arrangement for them and then spent a lot of his time driving people to the police station to file complaints after altercations with settlers. But Ali doesn't have much hope that the police will help them. In the last two decades, 94% of settler violence investigations ended without charges, according to human rights organization, Yesh Din. Still, Ali goes to the police because he wants to have a record of everything in case they end up in court in the future.
在接送孩子们上学几个月后，阿里为他们找到了不同的安排，然后花了很多时间开车送人去警察局，在与定居者发生冲突后提交申诉。但阿里对警察能帮助他们并没有太大希望。据人权组织Yesh Din称，在过去的二十年里，94%的定居者暴力案件最终都没有受到指控。尽管如此，阿里还是去警察局，因为他想保留一切记录，以防将来闹上法庭。
Things got so bad in the West Bank after October 7 that in 2024, for the first time, the United States imposed sanctions on individuals and entities there. Isaschar Maane, the settler leader who started the nearby shepherding outpost, caught the attention of the Biden administration. They placed sanctions on him and on his outpost. Sanctions can make it really hard to use credit cards or banks.
10月7日之后，约旦河西岸的情况变得如此糟糕，以至于2024年，美国首次对那里的个人和实体实施了制裁。Isaschar Maane，也就是建立附近牧羊前哨站的定居者领袖，引起了拜登政府的注意。他们对他和他的前哨站实施了制裁。制裁可能使使用信用卡或银行变得非常困难。
But in January, Donald Trump took office. And the same day, he decided to call off all sanctions on West Bank settlements and individuals. We don't know if that's why, but after that, settler violence intensified in Masafer Yatta, where Tuba is. And my next call with Ali, less than a week later, was different than all the others.
但在1月，唐纳德·特朗普上任。同一天，他决定取消对约旦河西岸定居点和个人的所有制裁。我们不知道这是否就是原因，但在那之后，马萨费尔亚塔（图巴所在地）的定居者暴力事件加剧了。不到一周后我与阿里的下一次通话，与之前的所有通话都不同。
Hello, hello?
喂，喂？
Hi. Can you hear me?
嗨。能听到我说话吗？
Can you hear me well?
你能听清吗？
I'd seen online that something big had happened in his village.
我在网上看到他的村庄发生了大事。
So I was sitting in the car, and I was drinking tea, and I was waiting for a call. Then suddenly, I saw them, six masked settlers running toward me. I saw them running from above the hill, down-- you know that-- you feel that it's like a storm. What I remember is like a sand storm or whatever, coming very fast towards us.
我当时坐在车里，正在喝茶，等着一个电话。然后突然，我看到了他们，六个蒙面定居者正向我跑来。我看到他们从山顶跑下来——你知道那种感觉——就像沙尘暴或什么的，非常快地冲向我们。
Ali gets out of his car. The parking area is in the middle of the compound. His family was all around-- his uncle, his grandma, his little cousins. He started screaming, telling them to run away. He was afraid the masked men were going to hurt them.
阿里从车里出来。停车区在院落中央。他的家人都在周围——他的叔叔、祖母、小表弟们。他开始尖叫，叫他们快跑。他害怕蒙面人会伤害他们。
But he had another fear-- the car. They're going to destroy the Duster. So after warning everyone, he went back to the car. But when he got back to the car, he saw the attackers were already there. One, he said, had an M16-- and the other, a bottle of gasoline. He gave up, running the other direction to join his family, and started filming.
但他还有另一个恐惧——车子。他们会毁掉这辆达斯特。所以在警告所有人后，他跑回车子。但当他回到车子时，他看到袭击者已经在那儿了。他说其中一个拿着M16——另一个拿着汽油瓶。他放弃了，朝另一个方向跑去和家人汇合，并开始拍摄。
In the video, the sheep are running. Someone is throwing rocks in the direction of the attackers. We see smoke, flames. Things break. Ali realizes his little cousins, Jurie and Jude, ages seven and nine, are still in the house, next to the fire. He yells at them to come out.
在视频中，羊在奔跑。有人向袭击者的方向扔石头。我们看到烟雾、火焰。东西在破碎。阿里意识到他的小表弟朱莉（Jurie）和朱德（Jude），分别7岁和9岁，还在火堆旁边的房子里。他大喊让他们出来。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
He yells at his family and neighbors to get away from the attackers.
他对他的家人和邻居大喊，让他们远离袭击者。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
The attackers, apparently done with what they wanted to do, run off. Just five minutes have passed. Ali goes back to the parking area, and we finally see the car in the video. Huge flames fill the interior and pour out of all the windows. Ali and I talked on Zoom two days after that happened.
袭击者显然完成了他们想做的事，跑开了。只过了五分钟。阿里回到停车区，我们终于在视频中看到了这辆车。巨大的火焰充满了车内，并从所有的窗户涌出。在事发两天后，我和阿里在Zoom上聊了聊。
I mean, luckily, I'm still alive, not being burned inside the car. So that's still a huge miracle and something to be thankful about.
我是说，幸运的是，我依然活着，没有被烧死在车里。所以那依然是一个巨大的奇迹，也是值得感恩的事情。
How are your cousins doing now, after this attack?
在这次袭击后，你的表弟们现在怎么样了？
Still very traumatized.
依然非常受创。
Ali said that the attackers went into the house where the kids were. They didn't have time to escape. The attackers hit Jurie with a rock on her back and Jude with a stick on his elbow.
阿里说袭击者进了孩子们所在的屋子。他们没时间逃跑。袭击者用石头打了朱莉的背，用棍子打了朱德的肘部。
Either they are not sharing. But when I was in their age, I was not saying anything-- anything to anyone, but I remember how much I am scared. Like, when I was six, I used to go to school, entering inside Chavat Maon and facing the most brutal attacks on my way to school. And I wanted to convince my parents not to go to school because of how much I was scared. So for sure, this is what the children are feeling.
要么是他们不分享。但我在他们这个年纪时，我什么也不会对任何人说，但我记得我是多么害怕。就像我六岁时，我经常去上学，进入Chavat Maon，在去学校的路上遭遇最残酷的攻击。我曾想说服我父母不要去学校，因为我是多么害怕。所以可以肯定的是，孩子们现在感受到的就是这些。
Why didn't you say anything when you were a kid?
你小时候为什么什么都不说？
I don't know. What would be the results of sharing? That's what I remember, that even if I share, there is nobody that is actually able to end this reality.
我不知道。分享的结果会是什么？我记得的是，即使我分享了，也没有人真的能够结束这种现实。
The second photo in Ali's room, it's the image of the car burning. The top part of the car is all fire. The bottom is charred. Smoke billows off to the very blue sky. The car was so important to Ali, to Tuba, that I was sure he would already have a plan to replace it. But he was paralyzed.
阿里房间里的第二张照片，是车子燃烧的照片。车顶全是火。车底被烧焦了。浓烟飘向非常蔚蓝的天空。这辆车对阿里、对图巴来说如此重要，以至于我确信他一定已经有了更换它的计划。但他瘫痪了。
The ability of getting another vehicle is not the most difficult part. The most difficult part is what will be the fate of a new car.
得到另一辆车的难度不是最困难的部分。最困难的部分是新车的命运会如何。
This is the most devastating part. This is the part that-- like, saying to me, don't get another car. Because if they burn this one, they might burn the other one. So if they can do that at 2:00 PM, not at midnight or not at 2:00 AM-- if they can do it at 2:00 PM, then this is a very scary situation.
这是最令人心碎的部分。这就像在对我说，别再买车了。因为如果他们烧了这一辆，他们可能还会烧掉下一辆。所以如果他们能在下午2点做这件事，而不是在午夜或凌晨2点——如果他们能在大白天2点做这件事，那这就是一种非常可怕的情况。
The police came to Tuba the same day to investigate. They sent a specialist to try to collect evidence. They took some rocks, looked for fingerprints in the car. But Ali says they didn't find anything. Two teenagers from Chavat Maon were arrested, but they were released less than a week later. Ali heard the case had been closed.
警察当天来到图巴进行调查。他们派了一名专家试图收集证据。他们拿走了一些石头，在车里寻找指纹。但阿里说他们什么也没发现。两个Chavat Maon的青少年被捕，但不到一周后就被释放了。阿里听说案件已经结案。
So many cars had been set on fire in recent years in the West Bank that a big Palestinian insurance company has started to offer settler attack insurance. They put out an ad with a picture of a car burning intensely.
近年来，约旦河西岸有太多汽车被放火焚烧，以至于一家大型巴勒斯坦保险公司已经开始提供“定居者攻击保险”。他们发布了一则广告，配上一张汽车剧烈燃烧的照片。
After the Zoom call, I didn't hear from Ali for weeks. He stopped answering my texts. He was silent on social media. Finally, he resurfaced. "Sorry for my silence," he texted. "I hope you're all right." Turned out, a few days after our call, he had been arrested.
在那次Zoom通话后，我好几周没收到阿里的消息。他不回复我的短信。他在社交媒体上也沉默了。终于，他重新出现了。“对不起我的沉默，”他发短信说。“希望你一切都好。”原来，在我们通话几天后，他被捕了。
He was released the same day, never charged, but the police kept his phone. I reached out to the police about this and about the car attack and never heard back. Ali felt like so much had been taken away from him-- his car, his documents, which he kept in his car, his phone.
他当天就被释放，从未受到指控，但警察扣押了他的手机。我曾就此以及汽车袭击事件联系过警方，但从未收到回复。阿里觉得他被夺走了太多东西——他的车、放在车里的证件、他的手机。
Everything was gone in just five days, like, everything. Everything.
一切都在五天内消失了，就像，一切。一切。
He got depressed and did something that no one here remembers him doing before. He took off, left Tuba for about a week and went to stay with a friend. His aunt, Aisha, told us that he never leaves. He's always there, ready to protect them.
他陷入了抑郁，并做了一件这里的人都不记得他以前做过的事。他离开了，离开图巴约一周，住到了朋友家。他的婶婶爱莎（Aisha）告诉我们，他从不离开。他总是待在那里，准备保护他们。
But Ali was the most scared he's ever been. He needed a beat to be alone, to recover. Life in Tuba was always a struggle with the settlers around. But Ali says that since October 7, it feels like they're pushing towards a specific goal.
但阿里是他有生以来最害怕的一次。他需要一点时间独自一人，恢复过来。图巴的生活与定居者的斗争一直存在。但阿里说，自10月7日以来，感觉他们正在向一个特定的目标推进。
They are working to kick the Palestinians out of their homes. This is what their message is, like, leave from here. The government, the Israeli occupation government, is preventing us from building houses, from building schools, from building any kind of medical or educational units, building roads. They are preventing us from surviving. And we survive with whatever we can.
他们正在努力把巴勒斯坦人赶出他们的家园。这就是他们的信息，比如，从这里离开。政府，以色列占领政府，正在阻止我们建造房屋、学校、医疗或教育单位、修建道路。他们正在阻止我们生存。而我们尽其所能地生存下来。
The settlers would say, if this is not enough to make you leave this land, we will do it with shooting, with making your life hell.
定居者会说，如果这还不足以让你离开这片土地，我们就会用枪击，用让你的生活变得地狱般来实现。
And what's your message back?
那你回馈给他们的信息是什么？
Are you trying to push me out of here? I didn't even decide to fucking live here. I wouldn't even choose to come to Masafer Yatta. Between, I don't know, Valdagno or Vicenza or Padova--
你们是在试图把我赶出去吗？我甚至没决定要他妈的住在这里。我甚至不会选择来马萨费尔亚塔。在，我不知道，瓦尔达尼奥（Valdagno）或维琴察（Vicenza）或帕多瓦（Padova）之间……
These are names of Italian towns. Ali loves Italy, but he's from Tuba. His family has lived there for generations.
这些是意大利城镇的名字。阿里热爱意大利，但他来自图巴。他的家族世代居住在那里。
It's my home. I was born here. Are you blaming me for something I ended up in?
这是我的家。我出生在这里。你们在责怪我陷入这种境地吗？
In June, settlers injured more Palestinians in the West Bank than they have in any other month over the past two decades, according to the UN. About a month ago, a friend of Ali's was shot and killed by a settler in a neighboring village. Ali's friend was filming a clash between the settler and some Palestinian residents, so it's all on video. The shooter claimed self-defense. He was arrested but was released after a few days. At least 11 Palestinians were also arrested, including Ali, who wasn't even there.
据联合国称，6月份，约旦河西岸定居者伤害的巴勒斯坦人比过去二十年任何一个月都多。大约一个月前，阿里的一位朋友在邻近村庄被一名定居者开枪打死。阿里的朋友当时正在拍摄定居者与一些巴勒斯坦居民之间的冲突，所以这一切都在录像中。枪手声称是自卫。他被捕了，但几天后就被释放了。至少有11名巴勒斯坦人也被捕，包括当时根本不在现场的阿里。
Back when I visited Ali in April, he told me he'd made a decision about the car. He was going to fix the Duster, which seemed impossible to me. But then in June, I called him.
当我四月份访问阿里时，他告诉我他已经决定了关于车子的事情。他打算修理那辆达斯特，这在我看来是不可能的。但在六月，我给他打了电话。
Hello, hello.
喂，喂。
Hi, Ali.
嗨，阿里。
Hi, Yael.
嗨，耶尔。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm good. Now the car is fixed. And it's already back in Tuba, parked here.
我很好。现在车修好了。它已经回到了图巴，停在这里。
Wow.
哇。
He sent the photo. The Dacia Duster was back.
他发来了照片。那辆达契亚达斯特回来了。
Yael Even Or. Coming up, an Israeli doctor tries to make sense of a case that does not make sense. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
耶尔·埃文·奥尔。接下来，一位以色列医生试图理清一个毫无道理的案件。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, The Other Territory. We're looking at what's been happening in the West Bank while the world's attention has been on Gaza.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《另一个领土》。我们要看看当世界注意力集中在加沙时，约旦河西岸正在发生什么。
And before we turn to Act 2, there are two quick snapshots that I want to share with you of life in the West Bank since October 7. Here's the first. It's a hall in a municipal park, a place where normally you would have a wedding or some other celebration, where 16 families are living, mats on the floor where they sleep.
在进入第二幕之前，我想和大家分享两个关于10月7日以来西岸生活的简短片段。这是第一个。这是一个市政公园的大厅，通常这里会举行婚礼或其他庆典，现在有16个家庭住在这里，垫子铺在地上睡觉。
(SUBJECT) NAWAL MOHAMMED MAHMOUD HAIKAL: [SPEAKING ARABIC]
(受访者) 纳瓦尔·穆罕默德·马哈茂德·海卡尔 (NAWAL MOHAMMED MAHMOUD HAIKAL): [阿拉伯语对话]
This room that you see here, this single room, 40 people sleep in it. There are no secrets. We change in front of each other. We sleep facing each other. There are no beds.
你在这里看到的这个房间，这个单独的房间，住着40个人。没有秘密。我们在彼此面前换衣服。我们睡着时面对着彼此。没有床。
That's Nawal Mohammed Mahmoud Haikal, 31, a single mother with two daughters. She spoke with journalist Ahmad Al-Bazz. Nawal's here because of something new that the Israeli army started doing in the West Bank in January. The country's defense minister announced that month that the military was going to start using the tactics that they've been using in Gaza to level houses and neighborhoods, but now they were going to do that in the West Bank.
那是31岁的纳瓦尔·穆罕默德·马哈茂德·海卡尔，一位有两个女儿的单身母亲。她接受了记者艾哈迈德·阿尔-巴兹（Ahmad Al-Bazz）的采访。纳瓦尔在这里是因为以色列军队在1月份开始在约旦河西岸做的一件新事。该国国防部长那个月宣布，军方将开始使用他们在加沙使用的策略来夷平房屋和社区，但现在他们要在约旦河西岸这样做。
And so Operation Iron Wall attacked four Palestinian refugee camps that are basically cities, with tanks and airstrikes and bulldozers tearing up the roads and knocking down buildings, displacing at least 30,000 people, according to the United Nations. It's unclear when or if they'll ever be able to move back. When Nawal talked to Ahmed, the Israeli military had just published a map indicating what houses they were going to demolish next.
于是“铁墙行动”袭击了四个巴勒斯坦难民营，这些难民营基本上就是城市，用坦克、空袭和推土机铲平道路，撞毁建筑物，据联合国称，导致至少3万人流离失所。目前还不清楚他们什么时候能够回去，或者是否能够回去。当纳瓦尔与艾哈迈德交谈时，以色列军方刚刚发布了一张地图，指示他们接下来要拆除哪些房屋。
(SUBJECT) NAWAL MOHAMMED MAHMOUD HAIKAL: [SPEAKING ARABIC]
(受访者) 纳瓦尔·穆罕默德·马哈茂德·海卡尔: [阿拉伯语对话]
Yeah, I saw it. That's my parents' home. They're threatening my parents' home with demolition.
是的，我看到了。那是我父母的家。他们威胁要拆除我父母的家。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
(SUBJECT) NAWAL MOHAMMED MAHMOUD HAIKAL: [SPEAKING ARABIC]
(受访者) 纳瓦尔·穆罕默德·马哈茂德·海卡尔: [阿拉伯语对话]
Yes, they have a circle around it. On my parents' home, they have two dots on it. They're threatening demolition. I live in my parents' home in a room. For us, the camp is our entire life.
是的，他们画了一个圆圈。在我父母的家上，他们标了两个点。他们威胁要拆除。我住在我父母家的一间房里。对我们来说，难民营就是我们的全部生命。
OK, here's a second snapshot. This one, a bright, shiny car dealership, chock-a-block with shiny new cars.
好吧，这是第二个片段。这是一个明亮、崭新的汽车经销店，挤满了闪闪发光的全新汽车。
So I'm looking around the showroom, two-floor showroom, and I don't see any customers.
我环顾这个展厅，两层楼的展厅，没看到任何顾客。
We have one, only.
我们有一个，只有一个。
Wait, who's the customer?
等等，那个顾客是谁？
Downstairs, that man, Abuslemann, Abuslemann. He's the customer, yes.
楼下，那个人，阿布斯莱曼（Abuslemann）。他是那个顾客，是的。
Abdalla AlNatsha is the showroom manager for Al Salaam Motors in the city of Hebron. This is a family business with a car lot, car repair, gas station, and-- curveball here-- French fry factory. And this is something I didn't really understand before I visited the West Bank-- is just what a disaster its economy is right now, for a bunch of reasons. But one of the big ones is that roughly 120,000 Palestinians used to commute from the West Bank into Israel.
阿卜杜拉·阿尔纳沙（Abdalla AlNatsha）是希伯伦市Al Salaam Motors汽车经销店的销售经理。这是一个家族企业，有停车场、汽车修理厂、加油站，还有——这里有个转折——薯条工厂。这也是我在访问约旦河西岸之前并没有真正理解的事情——就是它目前的经济状况是一场灾难，原因有很多。但其中一个重要原因是，曾经有大约12万巴勒斯坦人从约旦河西岸通勤到以色列。
And after October 7, the Israeli government forbade most of them from doing that, saying it was for security reasons, even though Israel's own security services, Shin Bet, said the risks could be managed. Shin Bet, in fact, said it would be riskier to leave so many people unemployed and discontent. But those tens of thousands of commuters were not just a backbone of the Palestinian economy. They were Abdalla's customers.
在10月7日之后，以色列政府禁止其中大多数人这样做，声称是出于安全原因，尽管以色列自己的安全部门“辛贝特”（Shin Bet）表示风险是可以管理的。事实上，辛贝特表示，让这么多人失业和不满风险更大。但那成千上万的通勤者不仅是巴勒斯坦经济的支柱。他们还是阿卜杜拉的客户。
They buy cars, new cars, or they buy lands, or they buy many things. And since the 7th of October, they all unemployed.
他们买车，新车，或者买土地，或者买很多东西。自10月7日以来，他们全都失业了。
People can't make their car payments, and the dealership's been repossessing vehicles. They've gone from selling 560 cars a year to 175. They've let a third of their employees go in all their businesses.
人们付不起车贷，车行一直在没收车辆。他们的销量从每年560辆车下降到175辆。他们在所有业务中解雇了三分之一的员工。
This bit also surprised me. Post-October 7, they say Israeli companies decided to stop selling them potatoes for the French fry factory. Abdalla also says that the local Palestinian government in the West Bank, the Palestinian Authority, owes them $6 million for construction and agricultural equipment that it bought.
这一部分也让我很惊讶。10月7日后，他们说以色列公司决定停止向他们的薯条工厂出售土豆。阿卜杜拉还说，约旦河西岸的当地巴勒斯坦政府——巴勒斯坦权力机构，因其购买的建筑和农业设备欠他们600万美元。
How soon do you think you'll get paid?
你认为多久能收到钱？
They send each month around $20,000 each month. Yes.
他们每个月寄大约2万美元。是的。
Well, that just barely covers the interest.
嗯，那几乎刚够支付利息。
Doesn't cover the interest.
不够支付利息。
Why can't they pay?
为什么他们付不出钱？
They can't pay because they don't have money.
他们付不出钱是因为他们没钱。
The Palestinian Authority doesn't have money in part because the Israeli government has withheld hundreds of millions of dollars in tax revenues from it. A World Bank report in June described its finances as a fiscal crisis. But because they are the only local buyers for this kind of gear, Abdalla continues to sell to them.
巴勒斯坦权力机构没钱，部分原因是以色列政府扣留了数亿美元的税收收入。世界银行6月的一份报告称其财政处于危机中。但因为他们是此类装备的唯一本地买家，阿卜杜拉继续卖给他们。
They still buying equipment now, yes.
他们现在还在买设备，是的。
And so how much does that thing cost?
那那个东西多少钱？
Each equipment, around $140,000.
每一台设备，大约14万美元。
And how much do they put down? How much do they pay when they buy, 30%?
他们付多少订金？他们买的时候付多少钱，30%？
No, nothing, zero, zero.
不，什么都没有，零，零。
How do I get that deal?
我怎么才能得到那种交易？
[LAUGHS] You have to be Palestinian Authority or one of them. Yes.
[笑] 你得是巴勒斯坦权力机构或者其中之一。是的。
This is the kind of family business where, once a week, they play volleyball together. It's brothers, and cousins, and Abdalla's uncle managing this business. And when I asked Abdalla's cousin, Wajdi, how this has affected him personally, how hard it's been, keeping the business going, he said that for the first time in his life, he's thought about moving away for a little bit.
这是一种每周一起打排球的家族企业。是兄弟、表兄弟，还有阿卜杜拉的叔叔在管理这项业务。当我问阿卜杜拉的表弟瓦吉迪（Wajdi），这对他的个人生活造成了什么影响，维持业务有多难时，他说他这辈子第一次考虑搬走一段时间。
--until this war finished, to go abroad.
——直到这场战争结束，到国外去。
Have you told your brother you've had these thoughts?
你告诉过你兄弟你有这些想法吗？
Yes.
是的。
What's he say?
他怎么说？
Shut up.
闭嘴。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Think about your business here and my family as well.
考虑一下你这里的业务和我的家人。
Every person I talk to in the West Bank seems stressed out about money. People with jobs are supporting people who lost jobs. Meanwhile, prices for food and gas are rising.
我在约旦河西岸谈到的每个人似乎都为钱感到压力。有工作的人在养活失业的人。与此同时，食物和天然气的价格正在上涨。
The only business I ran across that seemed to be doing OK is this guy, Bilal. He sells this incredible corn that is covered in brightly-colored powders and sauces, including this TikTok-ready fluorescent teal sauce, from a stand on the street.
我遇到的唯一一个生意看起来还行的就是这个人，比拉尔（Bilal）。他在街头的一个摊位上销售这种令人难以置信的玉米，上面覆盖着色彩鲜艳的粉末和酱汁，包括这种TikTok网红式的荧光青色酱汁。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
He's saying that ever since October 7, people are just sitting around without work, not doing anything. And they wander around the streets. And corn? They can afford. His business has improved.
他说自10月7日以来，人们只是无所事事，什么也不做。他们在街上徘徊。而玉米？他们买得起。他的生意反而好转了。
Act Two, What Happened to Walid. Since October 7, there have been a ton of arrests in the West Bank, doubling the number of Palestinians in Israeli prisons. Now it's over 10,000 people, according to the Israeli government. They're held as security prisoners, not on normal criminal charges. Most are from the West Bank. Over 3,600 are in something called administrative detention, where they're not charged with anything and there's no trial. They're just held based on classified evidence they don't see and can't contest.
第二幕，瓦利德（Walid）发生了什么。自10月7日以来，约旦河西岸发生了大量逮捕事件，以色列监狱中的巴勒斯坦人人数翻了一番。据以色列政府称，现在已经超过1万人。他们被作为安全囚犯拘留，而不是基于普通的刑事指控。大多数来自约旦河西岸。超过3600人处于所谓的“行政拘留”状态，即没有任何指控，也没有审判。他们仅仅基于他们看不到也无法抗辩的机密证据而被拘留。
Israeli prisons were notoriously overcrowded even before October 7. But in general, not many Palestinians died in Israeli prisons. In the year before October 7, it was two Palestinians, according to Physicians for Human Rights Israel. Since October 7, they count at least 93 Palestinians who died in Israeli custody. Naji Abbas works for Physicians for Human Rights and says after October 7--
即使在10月7日之前，以色列监狱也臭名昭著地拥挤。但总的来说，在以色列监狱中死亡的巴勒斯坦人并不多。根据“以色列医生促进人权组织”（Physicians for Human Rights Israel）的数据，在10月7日前的一年里，有两名巴勒斯坦人死亡。自10月7日以来，他们统计到至少有93名巴勒斯坦人在以色列拘留期间死亡。纳吉·阿巴斯（Naji Abbas）为“医生促进人权组织”工作，他说在10月7日之后——
It started to be weird. Because every week, every two weeks, you are getting a call saying there is a new death.
事情变得很奇怪。因为每隔一周、每两周，你都会接到一个电话说又有一个人死了。
So what is happening in these prisons? Well, in the wake of the Hamas attack on Israel, Israel's Minister of National Security, a far-right politician named Itamar Ben-Gvir, enacted some changes to the prison system. Ben-Gvir is a longtime provocateur and ultranationalist, somebody who's been convicted of supporting a Jewish terrorist organization and incitement to racism.
那么这些监狱里正在发生什么？嗯，在哈马斯袭击以色列之后，以色列国家安全部长、一个名为伊塔马·本-格维尔（Itamar Ben-Gvir）的极右翼政客，对监狱系统进行了一些改革。本-格维尔是一位长期的煽动者和极端民族主义者，曾因支持犹太恐怖组织和煽动种族主义而被定罪。
After the Hamas attacks, Ben-Gvir drastically limited security prisoners' contact with the outside world. It didn't matter whether they were accused of any connection to the Hamas attacks or Hamas itself. Families can't visit it anymore. They can't call.
哈马斯袭击后，本-格维尔大幅限制了安全囚犯与外界的联系。这无关他们是否被指控与哈马斯袭击或哈马斯本身有任何联系。家人不能再探视。也不能打电话。
The Red Cross, which had monitored conditions inside Israeli prisons since 1967, is now barred. In public statements, Ben-Gvir refers to all Palestinian security prisoners as terrorists. The physical conditions inside prisons have gotten a lot worse too. Scabies infestations are rampant and have been for over a year. I didn't know this-- scabies is a contagious skin disease caused by mites.
自1967年以来一直监测以色列监狱状况的红十字会现在被禁止进入。在公开声明中，本-格维尔将所有巴勒斯坦安全囚犯称为恐怖分子。监狱内部的物质条件也变得糟糕得多。疥疮感染泛滥，并且已经持续了一年多。我不知道这一点——疥疮是一种由螨虫引起的传染性皮肤病。
Prisoners tell their lawyers that a dozen people are sometimes crammed into a cell meant for five or six. And Ben-Gvir reduced prisoners' food rations to the minimum allowable by Israeli law, closed the canteens where prisoners could buy their own food.
囚犯们告诉他们的律师，有时十几个人被挤在仅供五六个人居住的牢房里。而且本-格维尔将囚犯的口粮减少到以色列法律允许的最低水平，关闭了囚犯可以购买自己食物的食堂。
Ben-Gvir didn't try to hide any of this. Last July, he posted on X, quote, "Since I assumed the position of minister of national security, one of the highest goals I have set for myself is to worsen the conditions of the terrorists in the prisons and to reduce their rights to the minimum required by law." He told the Associated Press that the purpose of these changes was to deter terrorism. Again, here's Naji Abbas of Physicians for Human Rights.
本-格维尔并没有试图隐瞒这一切。去年7月，他在X上发布消息称：“自从我担任国家安全部长以来，我为自己设定的最高目标之一，就是恶化监狱中恐怖分子的条件，并将他们的权利减少到法律要求的最低限度。”他告诉美联社，这些改变的目的是震慑恐怖主义。再次重申，“医生促进人权组织”的纳吉·阿巴斯说：
By the Israeli law, the punishment for an offense or a crime or when you are charged with something, the punishment is limiting your freedom, taking your freedom of movement. That's the punishment. But Ben-Gvir, he was very clear from the day one in the office that he think that the conditions of the detention, not the detention itself, the conditions of the detention should be part of the punishment.
根据以色列法律，对于某种违规行为或犯罪行为，或者当你被指控某事时，惩罚是限制你的自由，剥夺你的行动自由。那才是惩罚。但本-格维尔从上任第一天起就很清楚，他认为拘留的条件，而不是拘留本身，拘留的条件应该作为惩罚的一部分。
Palestinian prisoners began dying, many of them not very old, in their 40s, 30s, 20s. We don't know what happened to most of them. There have been a few autopsies that Physicians for Human Rights knows about, but even the families of the prisoners who get autopsies almost never get an autopsy report.
巴勒斯坦囚犯开始死亡，他们中的许多人并不老，四五十岁、二三十岁。我们不知道他们大多数人发生了什么。有些尸检，“医生促进人权组织”是知道的，但即使是那些获得尸检的囚犯家人，也几乎从未收到过尸检报告。
Here's what they get instead. They're allowed to send a doctor to observe the post-mortem examination on their behalf. This doctor doesn't actually participate in the autopsy. They just watch the procedure, then afterwards, write up an account, just a page or two, about what they saw.
这就是他们得到的替代方案。他们被允许派遣一名医生代表家人观察死后检查。这名医生实际上并不参与尸检。他们只是观看过程，然后写下一份一两页的记录，关于他们所看到的。
And since October 7, their observations, these written reports, have become one of the only windows into what is happening to security prisoners inside Israeli prisons today.
自10月7日以来，他们的观察报告，这些书面报告，已成为了解当今以色列监狱内安全囚犯情况的仅有的窗口之一。
Dana Chivvis has the story of one of those accounts.
达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）讲述了其中一个故事。
The place where these autopsies are performed is called Abu Kabir. It's in Tel Aviv. It's the Israeli government's forensic medicine institute. Since October 7, courts have dictated that only Israeli doctors can attend autopsies on behalf of the families. So Physicians for Human Rights went in search of Israeli doctors who'd be willing to go on behalf of Palestinian families.
进行这些尸检的地方叫阿布·卡比尔（Abu Kabir）。它在特拉维夫。它是以色列政府的法医学研究所。自10月7日以来，法院规定只有以色列医生才能代表家人参加尸检。所以“医生促进人权组织”去寻找愿意代表巴勒斯坦家庭参加的以色列医生。
One of the people they called was Dr. Daniel Solomon, an Israeli physician born in Italy. He's on the board of Physicians for Human Rights, volunteers with their mobile medical clinic in the West Bank, a do-gooder kind of guy. Daniel had never been to an autopsy before. He's a surgeon, not a forensic pathologist-- those are the doctors specially trained to do autopsies. But Daniel said, sure, he'd go. He didn't have much time to prepare.
他们打电话寻找的人之一是丹尼尔·所罗门（Daniel Solomon）医生，一位出生在意大利的以色列医生。他是“医生促进人权组织”的董事会成员，也是他们西岸移动医疗诊所的志愿者，那种做好事的人。丹尼尔以前从未参加过尸检。他是一名外科医生，而不是法医病理学家——那是专门受过尸检训练的医生。但丹尼尔说，当然，他会去。他没太多时间准备。
I looked a bit online on how an autopsy's performed and how maybe a report can look like. And that was it.
我在网上看了一点关于尸检是如何进行的，以及报告可能是什么样子的。就是这样。
Daniel had also never been inside Abu Kabir, the forensic Institute, though he'd jogged by it a bunch. The first time Daniel went, it was only three weeks after the Hamas attacks on October 7. The staff at Abu Kabir was still processing the remains of Israelis who had been killed.
丹尼尔也从未进过法医学研究所，尽管他经常在那边慢跑。丹尼尔第一次去时，距离哈马斯10月7日的袭击只有三周。阿布·卡比尔的工作人员当时还在处理被杀害的以色列人的遗体。
In a different room down the hall, Daniel observed the autopsies of two Palestinian prisoners that day. Over the course of the next year, he went to five of these autopsies, all Palestinian men from the West Bank who had died in Israeli prisons. After each one, Daniel wrote up his observations.
在大厅另一端的房间里，丹尼尔那天观察了两名巴勒斯坦囚犯的尸检。在接下来的一年里，他参加了五次这样的尸检，都是在以色列监狱中死亡的西岸巴勒斯坦男性。每次之后，丹尼尔都写下了他的观察结果。
One had, quote, "multiple signs of physical assault and injury." Another had "a relatively recent head trauma." Daniel saw conditions he assessed as treatable. One man's lungs were in the worst shape Daniel had ever seen. One of the lungs was surrounded by pus and completely collapsed. He was 23. Daniel's view was that, based on the condition of the lungs, the man would have been coughing violently and noticeably for at least a week.
其中一人，“有多种身体袭击和受伤的迹象。”另一人“有相对较新的头部创伤。”丹尼尔看到了他认为可以治疗的情况。一个人的肺部处于丹尼尔所见过的最糟糕的状态。其中一个肺被脓液包围，完全塌陷。他才23岁。丹尼尔的观点是，基于肺部的状况，那个人至少会剧烈且明显地咳嗽一周。
Daniel's used to seeing bodies inside and out. He's a surgeon. Standing there, observing during the autopsies, taking notes, he kept a practiced emotional distance from the body, same as he does when he's in surgery.
丹尼尔习惯了看到人体内外。他是一名外科医生。站在那里，在尸检过程中观察，做笔记，他保持了一种练习过的情感距离，就像他在手术中一样。
And then this March, there was Walid Ahmad, 17 years old. Daniel had read about Walid's death in the news. It made international headlines, the first Palestinian teenager to die inside an Israeli prison since Israel took over the West Bank in 1967, according to Physicians for Human Rights. Walid was from the West Bank, a town called Silwad.
然后在今年三月，发生了瓦利德·艾哈迈德（Walid Ahmad），17岁。丹尼尔在新闻中读到了瓦利德的死讯。这成了国际新闻头条，据“医生促进人权组织”称，这是自1967年以色列接管西岸以来，第一个在以色列监狱中死亡的巴勒斯坦青少年。瓦利德来自西岸，一个叫西尔瓦德（Silwad）的城镇。
Palestinian officials told reporters he had fallen and hit his head, citing other prisoners' accounts. When Daniel got to Abu Kabir for Walid's autopsy, the staff there did something they'd never done on any of his previous visits. They warned him about what he was about to see.
巴勒斯坦官员告诉记者他摔倒撞到了头，援引了其他囚犯的陈述。当丹尼尔到达阿布·卡比尔进行瓦利德的尸检时，那里的工作人员做了他们在他以前的访问中从未做过的事。他们警告他即将看到什么。
They were telling me-- they were commenting before he came in to kind of like, get ready. He doesn't look good. The moment they placed his body on the autopsy table, I understood that I was dealing with something that I was not actually prepared to witness. The way he looked, it's hard to describe. It was difficult for me to even call it malnutrition. This is how starvation looks like.
他们在进入之前评论说——为了让他做好准备。他看起来不太好。当他们把他的身体放在尸检台上时，我明白了我将要目睹一些我并未准备好见证的事情。他的样子，很难描述。我甚至很难称之为营养不良。这就是饥饿的样子。
I think the only thing that comes close to that, in my opinion, is really those pictures of the Holocaust. That's how bad it was. And I deal with cancer patients. I've seen anorexia. I've seen people get as thin as it gets. I honestly have never seen someone looking like he did.
我认为在我看来，唯一能与之相比的就是大屠杀的照片。情况就是那么糟。我处理过癌症患者。我见过厌食症。我见过人变得尽可能瘦。我真的从未见过有人看起来像他那样。
This interview was several months ago, before photos of starvation in Gaza were widespread. In the news stories about Walid, there was a photo of him from right before he was arrested. Walid looks like a strapping teenage boy, dirty blond hair, the beginnings of a beard. He's fit, a soccer star, hoping to join the Palestinian national team, nothing at all like the body Daniel was seeing on the metal table in front of him.
这次采访是在几个月前，在加沙饥饿的照片广泛传播之前。关于瓦利德的新闻报道中，有一张他被捕前拍的照片。瓦利德看起来像个强壮的青少年，深金色的头发，胡子刚长出来。他很健康，是个足球明星，希望能加入巴勒斯坦国家队，和他面前金属台上丹尼尔看到的尸体完全不像。
It's just like two absolutely different persons. It was really beyond recognition.
这就像是两个完全不同的人。真的无法辨认了。
Again, Daniel's account is not an official autopsy report. He doesn't have access to additional information, for instance, tests done on Walid's body after the autopsy. He doesn't know for sure how Walid got to look the way he did at the end. But his assessment is that however it happened--
再说一次，丹尼尔的叙述不是正式的尸检报告。他无法获得额外信息，例如尸检后对瓦利德尸体进行的测试。他并不确切知道瓦利德最后是怎么变成那样的。但他的评估是，无论发生了什么——
Starvation, at the end of the day, killed him because it exposed him so much to other diseases that might have been treatable and that, in his case, just become fatal.
归根结底是饥饿杀死了他，因为它让他太容易受到其他本可治疗的疾病的侵袭，而这些疾病在他身上变得致命。
Daniel addressed his account of the autopsy, quote, "to the family of Walid Ahmad." Walid was a case where, in Daniel's view, everything he was seeing could have been treated-- his significant weight loss, also scabies. Daniel's account also said Walid had an inflammation of the colon. He did not see any evidence of a head injury, external or internal.
丹尼尔把他的尸检陈述地址写为“瓦利德·艾哈迈德的家人”。在丹尼尔看来，瓦利德是一个如果得到治疗，他所看到的一切本都可以治疗的案例——他严重的体重减轻，还有疥疮。丹尼尔的陈述还说，瓦利德有结肠炎症。他没有看到任何头部受伤的证据，无论是外部还是内部。
Walid's body had been sent to Abu Kabir with notes from the prison medical clinic. Daniel read them and wrote in his account that in December, Walid had gone to the prison medical clinic and, quote, "mentioned that he did not have access to sufficient amounts of food." Daniel said that according to the prison notes, Walid had said other prisoners were taking his food. The month before Walid died, he went to the clinic two more times.
瓦利德的遗体被从监狱医疗诊所带着说明送到阿布·卡比尔。丹尼尔读了这些说明，并在他的记录中写道，12月，瓦利德曾去过监狱医疗诊所，并“提到他没有获得足够数量的食物。”丹尼尔说，根据监狱说明，瓦利德曾说其他囚犯拿走了他的食物。在瓦利德去世前一个月，他又去了诊所两次。
Israeli law says that, quote, "A prisoner shall be entitled to the medical care necessary to maintain his health and to appropriate monitoring conditions as stipulated by an IPS physician." IPS is Israel Prison Service.
以色列法律规定，“囚犯有权获得维持健康所必需的医疗护理，并有权获得经监狱管理局医生规定的适当监测条件。” IPS是以色列监狱管理局。
The relevant thing is that he was someone who was under the responsibility of the Israeli Prison Service. He was under a system that failed him so badly.
相关的是，他是一个处于以色列监狱管理局责任下的人。他身处一个让他如此严重失败的系统中。
The Israel Prison Service told me it doesn't comment on individual cases. But they sent a statement saying in part, quote, "All inmates are held according to legal procedures. And their basic rights, including access to medical care, are upheld by professionally trained staff, subject to internal and external review."
以色列监狱管理局告诉我，他们不对个案发表评论。但他们发了一份声明，部分写道：“所有囚犯均按照法律程序关押。他们的基本权利，包括获得医疗护理的权利，由训练有素的工作人员维护，并受内部和外部审查。”
It took Daniel a couple of days to write his account.
丹尼尔花了几天时间写他的记录。
Just because I wanted it to be accurate. And sometimes, it's really not that easy to find the wording, like somewhere in between something that a physician can understand but something that also the family can understand.
因为我希望它准确。有时，找到措辞真的没那么容易，某种介于医生能理解的东西和家人也能理解的东西之间。
Daniel's account with his observations went to Walid's father, Khaled. Until he got it, he didn't know anything about how his son died or why. He says he just got a call one night close to midnight, telling him Walid was dead. Khaled is the only one in the family who read all of Daniel's report. He said Walid's mother, siblings, and aunts couldn't bear to finish it.
丹尼尔的观察记录发给了瓦利德的父亲哈立德（Khaled）。在他收到记录之前，他根本不知道他儿子是怎么死的或为什么死。他说他只是在午夜临近时接到一个电话，说瓦利德死了。哈立德是家里唯一读完丹尼尔所有报告的人。他说瓦利德的母亲、兄弟姐妹和婶婶不忍心看完。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
Before receiving the report, knowing that Walid was in good health, my first thought it was a result of torture or beating.
在收到报告之前，知道瓦利德身体健康，我的第一个想法是虐待或殴打的结果。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
I sought help from a doctor here in town. And he explained to me the entire report, like for medical terms. He explained all the details and all the different small parts in it.
我找了镇上的一位医生寻求帮助。他向我解释了整个报告，就像医学术语一样。他解释了所有的细节以及其中所有的不同小部分。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
It just made it more shocking. Shocking.
这让它更加令人震惊。震惊。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
My son, Walid, was an athletic young man. I don't know what they did to him in prison.
我的儿子瓦利德，是个运动型青年。我不知道他们在监狱里对他做了什么。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
Walid, Khaled said, had cared how he looked, showered twice a day. In photos, he's always dressed nicely, usually in name brands-- Hilfiger, Polo.
哈立德说，瓦利德很在乎自己的长相，一天洗两次澡。在照片中，他总是打扮得很得体，通常穿名牌——Hilfiger，Polo。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
Walid liked things that were-- for clothes, he liked the nicest things. He wanted the nicest, best things. He did not used to ask, of course. But I knew what he liked. When we would go out to buy clothes, I knew his taste. He liked everything to be neat.
瓦利德喜欢那些——对于衣服，他喜欢最漂亮的。他想要最漂亮的、最好的东西。当然，他不会去要求。但我知道他喜欢什么。当我们出去买衣服时，我知道他的品味。他喜欢一切都整齐。
Walid was planning to go to university next year to study finance and banking, Khaled told me. Some nights after school, and over the summer break, he worked at Khaled's shop. Khaled's mother was Brazilian. He imports nuts and coffee from Brazil and elsewhere.
哈立德告诉我，瓦利德计划明年上大学学习金融和银行。放学后和寒暑假期间，他会在哈立德的店里帮忙。哈立德的母亲是巴西人。他从巴西和其他地方进口坚果和咖啡。
Walid was a senior in high school. From what I can see, his social media is filled with photos of him and his friends, often preening, often in front of cars, mixed in with memorial posts for young men who have died and support for others who are in prison. In a couple photos, people are holding guns. From the outside, it's hard to tell what any of that adds up to. But I showed all this to a Palestinian journalist, who said he's seen hundreds of accounts like this.
瓦利德是一名高中四年级学生。据我所见，他的社交媒体上充满了和他朋友的照片，经常自恋，经常在车前，还夹杂着为那些已经去世的年轻人写的纪念贴，以及对其他狱中人的支持。在几张照片中，人们拿着枪。从外部看，很难判断这一切加起来意味着什么。但我把所有这些给了一位巴勒斯坦记者看，他说他见过数百个这样的账户。
Walid had never been arrested before, his lawyers say. The military came in the middle of the night last September 2024. Middle of the night raids are the standard way the military arrests Palestinians in the West Bank, including minors. That was true even before October 7. But there have been so many more arrests since then.
他的律师说，瓦利德以前从未被捕过。军方在2024年9月的一个深夜闯入。深夜突袭是以色列军方在约旦河西岸逮捕巴勒斯坦人（包括未成年人）的标准方式。即使在10月7日之前也是如此。但从那以后逮捕事件多了很多。
Khaled says everyone was asleep when they came-- him and his wife, all four kids. At 17, Walid was the oldest. Khaled estimates there were 25 soldiers. He says some of them broke two doors, came into the house, and smashed the windows of the front room, flipped over couches, tore curtains.
哈立德说他们来的时候每个人都在睡觉——他和他的妻子，四个孩子全在。17岁时，瓦利德是老大。哈立德估计有25名士兵。他说他们中的一些人打破了两扇门，闯入屋内，打碎了前厅的窗户，掀翻了沙发，撕碎了窗帘。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
As soon as they entered, they started saying to me, you're Hamas. You're Hezbollah. I told them, I am neither Hamas nor Hezbollah. They went into the kids' room and terrified them. I told the soldiers, wait, wait. Let me-- so then I went and gathered all the children and put them here in this spot.
他们一进来，就开始对我说，你是哈马斯。你是真主党。我告诉他们，我既不是哈马斯也不是真主党。他们走进孩子们的房间，吓坏了他们。我对士兵说，等一下，等一下。让我——所以我就去把所有的孩子聚在一起，把他们放在这个地方。
Khaled says Walid had on only his underwear and a tank top when they took him away.
哈立德说他们把瓦利德带走时，他只穿了内衣和一件背心。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
When they were arresting Walid, I said to the officer, let us just put pants on him. Because that night, it was a bit cold. I said, let us put pants and a jacket on him. But the officer refused.
当他们逮捕瓦利德时，我对军官说，让我们给他穿上裤子吧。因为那天晚上，天有点冷。我说，让我们给他穿上裤子和外套。但军官拒绝了。
When I asked the Israeli military about Khaled's account of the arrest, they told me that no one filed a report complaining about how it was handled. Two weeks after Walid was arrested, five months before his death, he was charged with producing an explosive or incendiary device, which is identified as a Molotov cocktail, throwing an explosive device, and arson. The charging document is remarkably vague. There are no specific locations saying where the crimes allegedly happened or specific times. One incident supposedly took place, quote, "sometime during the year 2022."
当我询问以色列军方关于哈立德对逮捕经过的描述时，他们告诉我没有人报告抱怨处理方式。瓦利德被捕两周后，也就是他去世前五个月，他被指控制造爆炸或燃烧装置，即莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，投掷爆炸装置，以及纵火。这份起诉书模糊得令人惊奇。没有具体的地点说明犯罪据称发生在何处，也没有具体的时间。据称其中一起事件发生在“2022年某时”。
One of Walid's lawyers pointed out that there's no complainant listed on the charging document, nobody who went to the authorities and said, this kid threw a Molotov cocktail at my house and caused damage to me. If there were, he said, there would have been more specificity to the charges.
瓦利德的一名律师指出，起诉书上没有列出任何投诉人，没有人向当局投诉说，这个孩子向我的房子投掷了莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，对我造成了损害。他说，如果有的话，指控会更具体。
The evidence against him seemed to be allegations from two other prisoners. Walid was being tried under Israeli military law, where the standards of evidence are lower than in civilian court. All Palestinians in the West Bank are subject to military law. That's been true for almost 60 years.
针对他的证据似乎是另外两名囚犯的指控。瓦利德是在以色列军事法下受审，那里的证据标准比民事法庭低。所有约旦河西岸的巴勒斯坦人都受军事法管辖。这一点近60年来一直如此。
In response to my questions about Walid's case, the Israeli military sent a statement that said, in part, that Walid was, quote, "imprisoned based on well-founded evidence of his offenses, including testimonies from other operatives against him." It's not clear if Walid did any of the things he was charged with. His lawyer said he denied it, and Walid died before he could give his defense or take a plea.
针对我对瓦利德案件的询问，以色列军方发了一份声明，部分表示瓦利德是“基于其犯罪的有根据的证据被监禁，包括来自其他行动者对他的证词”。目前尚不清楚瓦利德是否做了他被指控的那些事。他的律师说他否认了，瓦利德在还没能进行辩护或认罪前就去世了。
Khaled spent six months trying to find out what was happening to his son in prison. He learned pretty quickly that Walid was in Megiddo prison, hours away, outside the West Bank in Israel. No one in the family was allowed to communicate with him. They couldn't visit him.
哈立德花了六个月时间试图找出他儿子在监狱里发生了什么。他很快得知瓦利德在米吉多（Megiddo）监狱，离这里很远，在约旦河西岸之外的以色列。家里没有人被允许与他交流。他们不能探视他。
Throughout last fall and winter, Khaled went to Walid's court hearings in a military courtroom in the West Bank. The prosecutors and judges were all in the Israeli military. Walid appeared remotely over a video connection from prison. Khaled saw Walid for the last time like this, on a TV screen during a court hearing in February.
整个去年秋天和冬天，哈立德都在西岸的军事法庭参加瓦利德的法庭听证会。检察官和法官都是以色列军方的人。瓦利德通过监狱的视频连接远程出庭。哈立德最后一次见到瓦利德就是这样，在2月份的一次听证会上的电视屏幕上。
Could you tell how he looked physically?
你能看出来他身体状况如何吗？
I saw his face. Of course, we could only see him from here and up. His face was thinner. But the day I saw him, he smiled to my face, and I smiled back.
我看到了他的脸。当然，我们只能从这里往上看。他的脸更瘦了。但那天我见到他时，他对着我的脸笑了，我也回以微笑。
Khaled says he saw him for only about 20 seconds. Walid died six weeks later on March 22. The family was informed two days after.
哈立德说他只见到他大约20秒。瓦利德六周后于3月22日去世。家人两天后才被告知。
What Physicians for Human Rights and others were learning around the time Walid died sheds light on how Walid might have become so frail in the weeks between when his father last saw him on screen and his death.
“医生促进人权组织”和其他人在瓦利德去世前后了解到的情况，揭示了瓦利德在父亲最后一次在屏幕上见到他到他去世之间的几周里是如何变得如此虚弱的。
They learned that some sort of gastrointestinal illness was going around the prison. Lawyers for Palestinians in Israeli Prisons reported seeing their clients deteriorate from one visit to the next, getting very thin. Prisoners, including minors, told their lawyers they were vomiting, had diarrhea, were sometimes fainting, and were rapidly losing weight. Khaled, Walid's father, had heard about it from a friend of Walid's, who'd been in the same prison and was released.
他们了解到某种肠胃疾病正在监狱中传播。巴勒斯坦在以囚犯的律师报告说，看到他们的客户从一次探视到下一次探视不断恶化，变得非常瘦。囚犯，包括未成年人，告诉他们的律师他们呕吐、腹泻、有时晕厥，并且体重迅速下降。瓦利德的父亲哈立德，从瓦利德的一个朋友那里听说过，那个朋友和他在同一所监狱，后来被释放了。
We heard about it from another teenager, who was also held at Megiddo prison at the same time as Walid and knew Walid. He's 16 years old, and he first spoke to reporter Hagar Shezaf at the Israeli newspaper, Haaretz. In the Haaretz story, he's called Ibrahim. It's not his real name. I'm going to use that name for him too.
我们是从另一个十几岁的孩子那里听说这件事的，他也和瓦利德同时被关在米吉多监狱，也认识瓦利德。他16岁，第一次向以色列《国土报》（Haaretz）的记者哈加尔·谢扎夫（Hagar Shezaf）讲述。在《国土报》的故事中，他被称为易卜拉欣（Ibrahim）。这不是他的真名。我也会用这个名字称呼他。
Ibrahim's experience in prison mirrored Walid's in several important ways. And he was an eyewitness to Walid's last days. He talked to my producer in the West Bank. Ibrahim and Walid were arrested around the same time. He said Walid joked around a lot. He was a talker.
易卜拉欣在监狱中的经历在几个重要方面与瓦利德相似。他是瓦利德最后日子的目击者。他与我在西岸的制片人交谈。易卜拉欣和瓦利德大约在同一时间被捕。他说瓦利德很爱开玩笑。他是个健谈的人。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
Yes, I talked to him a lot. Almost every day, I talked to him. When he used to live with me in the same cell, I used to talk to him. We used to talk about food because we were starving.
是的，我和他聊了很多。几乎每天我都和他聊。当他和我住在同一个牢房时，我经常和他说话。我们经常谈论食物，因为我们饿得要命。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语对话]
And he would say to me, when we get out, God willing, that we will go to my father's store. We will eat cashews and nuts.
他会对我说，等我们出去了，上帝保佑，我们会去我父亲的店里。我们要吃腰果和坚果。
Ibrahim said they never got enough food. He said everyone was hungry and everyone stole food from each other. After the first two months, they weren't in the same cell anymore. And then around the beginning of March, Ibrahim got sick, was dropping weight, vomiting, diarrhea.
[阿拉伯语对话]
He said when he saw Walid, he noticed Walid had similar symptoms. Ibrahim was so sick, he said, he couldn't make it to the toilet in time. He said his sheets were filthy. He couldn't wash his clothes. He smelled. It made him feel like a little child.
易卜拉欣说他们从来没得到足够的食物。他说每个人都很饿，每个人都偷别人的食物。头两个月后，他们没在同一个牢房了。然后大约在3月初，易卜拉欣生病了，体重下降、呕吐、腹泻。
Ibrahim told Haaretz that when he asked for medical help, he was given an over-the-counter drug similar to Tylenol and was told to eat rice and drink water. He said five of his nine cellmates had the same symptoms. Ibrahim said Walid deteriorated visibly. He said he saw Walid the morning he died.
他说当他看到瓦利德时，他注意到瓦利德也有类似的症状。易卜拉欣说他病得太重，来不及赶到厕所。他说他的床单很脏。他洗不了衣服。他身上有味道。这让他感觉像个小孩子。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
易卜拉欣告诉《国土报》，当他寻求医疗帮助时，他被给予了一种类似于泰诺的非处方药，并被告知吃米饭喝水。他说他的九个同室囚犯中有五个有同样的症状。易卜拉欣说瓦利德肉眼可见地恶化了。他说他在瓦利德去世的那天早上看到了他。
OK. So we were out for the break. Everybody ran towards the bathrooms. His body was weak. He couldn't walk a lot. He couldn't run. Neither could I. He opened the cell door. We came out towards the bathrooms. Suddenly, he fell on the floor and started bleeding from his mouth.
[阿拉伯语对话]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
好的。我们在休息时间出来。每个人都跑向浴室。他的身体很虚弱。他走不动太多路。他也跑不动。我也跑不动。他打开牢房门。我们向浴室走去。突然，他倒在地上，嘴里开始出血。
They told us to go back to the cells. We thought it was going to be a crackdown and beating. But when we went back into the cells, Walid was bleeding out of his mouth. They put him on the gurney and took him.
[阿拉伯语对话]
After Walid died, Ibrahim said the prison made a few changes. They separated out the thinnest prisoners and gave them more food, brought in a washing machine. In May, six weeks after Walid died, Ibrahim was released from prison 11 days early.
他们让我们回牢房。我们以为会有一场镇压和殴打。但当我们回到牢房时，瓦利德嘴里在出血。他们把他抬上担架带走了。
Ibrahim says he weighed 159 pounds when he entered prison. When he left, he was only 101 pounds, according to the parole board. The parole board noted he was, quote, "difficult to look at and a cause of great concern."
瓦利德去世后，易卜拉欣说监狱做了一些改变。他们把最瘦的囚犯分出来给他们更多的食物，带进了一台洗衣机。5月，在瓦利德去世六周后，易卜拉欣被提前11天从监狱释放。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
易卜拉欣说他入狱时重159磅。据假释委员会称，他离开时只有101磅。假释委员会指出他“样子很难看，引起了极大关注”。
This is for Walid.
[阿拉伯语对话]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
这是为了瓦利德。
And this is for Walid.
[阿拉伯语对话]
When I visited Khaled in April at the family's home-- it's pretty-- stone, lots of tall windows-- he showed me Walid's trophies and ribbons on a display shelf in their sitting room. They were for soccer-- Walid was a goalie-- and also for kickboxing.
这也是为了瓦利德。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
四月份我访问哈立德在他们家的房子时——很漂亮——石头房子，有很多高大的窗户——他在客厅的陈列架上给我看了瓦利德的奖杯和丝带。那是关于足球的——瓦利德是守门员——还有自由搏击。
This also was for Walid.
[阿拉伯语对话]
And also a competition known as the math Olympics.
这个也是瓦利德的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
还有一项被称为数学奥林匹克的比赛。
I put him in private school since he was bright and driven. He was well known for his intelligence and his excellence in math.
[阿拉伯语对话]
The kid in Khaled's head was Walid suspended in amber, Walid from before he was arrested, this energetic teenager barreling towards adulthood. He had big ideas for the family business. He wanted to expand, open more stores, learn different roasting and grinding methods, get into cappuccino and espresso. He wanted the company to be a brand name.
因为他聪明且有动力，我把他送进了私立学校。他以聪明和数学出色而闻名。
Khaled had been planning to take Walid on a trip to Brazil this summer. Walid had never been. He had just signed Walid up for driving lessons when he was arrested. They were a close family.
哈立德心里的孩子是瓦利德定格在琥珀中的样子，是逮捕前的瓦利德，那个朝着成年奔跑的充满活力的青少年。他为家族企业有宏大的想法。他想扩张，开更多的店，学习不同的烘焙和研磨方法，尝试卡布奇诺和浓缩咖啡。他想让公司成为一个品牌。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
哈立德计划今年夏天带瓦利德去巴西旅行。瓦利德从来没去过。他刚在瓦利德被捕时给他报了驾校。他们是一个亲密的家庭。
We have a table here in the house, in the middle. And we would spend so much time chasing each other around the table. I would come from here. He would go from there. I would go from there. He would come from here. I would climb the table to get to him. But because he was in good shape, he would get away. His mom would feel bad for him and tell me, poor him, you keep chasing after him. I tell her, he is the one chasing me.
[阿拉伯语对话]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
我们屋里有一张桌子，在中间。我们会花很多时间绕着桌子追逐。我会从这里来。他会从那边走。我会从那边走。他会从这里来。我会爬上桌子去抓他。但因为他身体素质好，他总能逃掉。他妈妈会心疼他，对我说，可怜的他，你一直追着他不放。我告诉她，是他一直在追我。
The reason Khaled agreed to an autopsy in the first place is that his lawyer told him it could help him get Walid's body back. It's the practice of the Israeli government to hold onto bodies of Palestinian prisoners, to keep them as bargaining chips. Hamas does it too with Israeli bodies.
[阿拉伯语对话]
Since October 7, Israel hasn't released the bodies of any Palestinian prisoners, including Walid's. So Khaled is still waiting. He still hasn't buried his son.
哈立德起初同意尸检的原因是他的律师告诉他这可以帮助他找回瓦利德的尸体。扣留巴勒斯坦囚犯的尸体，将它们作为筹码，是以色列政府的做法。哈马斯也用以色列人的尸体这样做。
Dana Chivvis.
自10月7日以来，以色列没有释放任何巴勒斯坦囚犯的尸体，包括瓦利德的。所以哈立德还在等。他还没能埋葬他的儿子。
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis and Yael Even Or, edited by Nancy Updike, David Kestenbaum, and myself. The people who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Chana Joffe-Walt, Katherine Rae Mando, Valerie Kipnis, Andrea Marks, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor's Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
达娜·奇维斯。
Other people who worked on the show as reporters and producers-- Ahmad Al-Bazz, Jude Taha, Sawsan Khalife, and Hany Hawasly, editor Sara Yasin, translator Shani Aviram, Talia Krevsky, Bachar Al-Halabi and Dana Ballout, also voice actor Waleed Zuaiter.
我们今天的节目由达娜·奇维斯和耶尔·埃文·奥尔制作，南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）和我本人编辑。参与制作今天节目的人包括Jendayi Bonds、Michael Comite、Suzanne Gaber、Chana Joffe-Walt、Katherine Rae Mando、Valerie Kipnis、Andrea Marks、Stowe Nelson、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Ike Sriskandarajah、Lilly Sullivan、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Julie Whitaker和Diane Wu。我们的主编是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Henriette Chacar, Noa Cohen, Matt Duss, Oriel Eisner, Daniel Estrin, Kara Lee Francis, Neda Frayha, Ori Givati, Ramy Ghaly, Amel Guettatfi, Harlo Holmes, Matthew Hooper, the team at Hotspot Cover, Aida Kadin, Ariel Kahana, Jessica Montell and Dani Shenhar at HaMoked, Riham Nasra, Raviv Rose. Noa Sattath, Gabrielle Schonder, Stefan Schmitt, Guy Shalev, Ofer Shelah, Yehuda Shaul, Hagar Shezaf, and Seth Freed Wessler.
作为记者和制片人参与节目制作的其他人员——艾哈迈德·阿尔-巴兹、Jude Taha、Sawsan Khalife和Hany Hawasly，编辑Sara Yasin，翻译Shani Aviram、Talia Krevsky、Bachar Al-Halabi和Dana Ballout，以及配音演员Waleed Zuaiter。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who's like, yeah, yeah, Robert Frost. Two roads diverged in a yellow wood.
今天特别感谢Henriette Chacar、Noa Cohen、Matt Duss、Oriel Eisner、Daniel Estrin、Kara Lee Francis、Neda Frayha、Ori Givati、Ramy Ghaly、Amel Guettatfi、Harlo Holmes、Matthew Hooper，Hotspot Cover团队，Aida Kadin、Ariel Kahana、Jessica Montell和HaMoked的Dani Shenhar，Riham Nasra、Raviv Rose、Noa Sattath、Gabrielle Schonder、Stefan Schmitt、Guy Shalev、Ofer Shelah、Yehuda Shaul、Hagar Shezaf和Seth Freed Wessler。
But I have another road.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，他就像是，耶，耶，罗伯特·弗罗斯特。两条路在黄树林里分岔。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
但我还有另一条路。